Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Es ist soweit, nachdem wir nur knapp zwei Stunden damit verbracht haben, uns zu treffen, hinzusetzen, den Tisch freizuräumen, den Rechner aufzubauen, das Setup zu machen, Denis zu überreden, dann doch noch per Skype dabei zu sein, denn Denis ist heute etwas krank. Wo warst du denn, wo hast du dich denn rumgetrieben, Denis?
Auf dem Kongress.
Ey, wie cool. Da warst du ja bestimmt total alleine, oder? Teilweise alleine, abgesehen von den anderen 5.000 Leute, die da noch rumgelaufen sind.
Ich war ja im Hinterzimmer, da war ich teilweise alleine.
Ach so, das stimmt. Ja, dann stelle ich die Runde doch mal vor, das machen wir selten genug. Also, Denis am Apparat, heute mal über Skype, ein bisschen nasal, dann Erkältung. Du bist dann, also jetzt für uns gerade in diesem Moment, nicht links, aber du bist dann nachher auch links.
Ich war extra laut.
Im Livestream, den wir jetzt auch anhaben, bist du nicht links, aber später im Podcast bist du dann links. Und Max? Hallo Max?
Nicht krank. Nicht krank? Nicht krank.
Das ist gut.
Unkrank.
Ich bin auch total unverschont, total verschont geblieben von diesem ganzen Bakterien-Festival.
Ja, denk, da kommt es halt einfach noch. Was denkt ihr?
Das ist mein gestellter Körper.
Das dauert halt eine Weile, bis der Virus bei allen ankommt.
Tja, das kann natürlich auch sein. Aber das war ja Skype. Zumindest hat er es bis jetzt nicht geschafft.
Bist du? Du hast heimlich mit dem Internet-Explorer gesurft.
Hab ich gar nicht.
Womit wollen wir anfangen? Also ich denke, wir haben so verschiedene Themen auf der Liste. Wir können ja mal vielleicht mal so einen Ausblick geben. Jetzt gleich mal so zum Anfang. Wir müssen auf jeden Fall über den Kongress ein bisschen reden, aber vor allem denke ich mal über den iPhone-Talk. Hast du den gesehen, Denis? Du warst auch da, ne?
Ich war auf dem Kongress, habe mir aber keinen einzigen Vortrag angeguckt, weil das, wenn das so voll ist, das geht irgendwie gar nicht. Und danach habe ich flach gelegen und habe deswegen mein Hirn war matschig, habe mir noch nicht mal ein per Video angeguckt. Und den einzigen, den ich mir per Video angucken wollte, war dieser iPhone-Talk und der war horribel und deswegen habe ich es aufgegeben. Wie horribel? Wie Aufzeichnung? Ja, das, was ich gesehen habe, war total unscharf oder das war übersaturiert und man konnte überhaupt gar nichts lesen und nichts. Und deswegen habe ich das gelassen.
Verstehe.
War das so eine Live-Auszeichnung oder was?
Mit anderen Worten, ja, das war, also die früh veröffentlichten Videos waren in der Regel Mitschnitte von den Livestreams, weil die offiziellen Aufnahmen, die veröffentlicht werden, die sind dann noch so ein bisschen mit Metadaten angereichert. Da steckt dann schon noch mal ein bisschen Arbeit drin mit irgendwie Anfang und Ende schneiden und Titel davor packen und so. Das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur so mitgeschnitten und dann auf den Server geworfen, sondern da wird schon Arbeit investiert und das ist auch gut so. Wie man so schön sagt in Berlin. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie jetzt so der Veröffentlichungsstand ist. Es ist nicht alles draußen, aber es ist so das eine oder andere.
Das ist der totale Wildwuchs. Das gibt es alles in tausend Varianten und inzwischen blickt da irgendwie keiner mehr durch.
Ja, ja. Ich werde mal zusehen, dass ich da, sobald die iPod-kompatiblen Varianten draußen sind, da den Podcast zusammen machen, dann haben wir wieder Überblick. Ja, okay, gut, dann müssen wir so ein bisschen Gedenkensprotokoll machen, aber vielleicht schieben wir mal das Thema ein bisschen nach hinten. Dann würde ich gerne berichten, ich war beim Apple Store in München, ich könnte noch ein paar und muss geradezu hier nochmal über meine bisherigen Erlebnisse mit dem Drobo reden. Dann hatten wir gestern MacWorld, Keynote, die Philnote, die erste und ich hab beim Gucken gedacht so, er hat doch gar nicht abgenommen, bis ich es dann erst einen Moment gedauert hab.
Er hat doch zugenommen, ne?
Ist nicht dein Ernst.
Ja, das war ein bisschen bärlich. Ich hab ja während das losging, hab ich ja schon irgendwie alle geärgert, hab gesagt, Jungs, da kommt nichts über Hardware. Dann kam ja halt doch noch tatsächlich das, was vorher schon so ein bisschen spekuliert wurde, mit dem 17 Zoller, dass es endlich kommt und mit der eingebauten Batterie. Und dann kam ja noch das, was auch kurz vorher schon rum ist, das halt irgendwie mit dem iTunes, mit der DRM freien Musik, was ich ja fast am Ende für das größte Ereignis halte.
Deswegen haben sie das ja auch als nach hinten geschoben.
Ja, und ich hatte vorher schon so eine Ahnung, dass, wenn sie schon ihren letzten MacWorld-Keynote machen und wenn sowieso auch alle sagen, der Steve muss mal ein bisschen zurücktreten, nicht mal weil er krank ist, aber weil alle Leute denken, er wäre der Einzige und dann geht der Laden unter, dass sie ein bisschen parallel irgendwie noch halt den Phil und andere Leute ein bisschen was machen lassen müssen, dass sie den jetzt nicht den Phil irgendwie nur so einen Scheiß präsentieren lassen, sondern dem auch schon ein bisschen was geben, was ein bisschen cool ist. Und ich würde mal sagen, es war jetzt eine ganz normale Keynote. Also das Steve hat auch schon mal Keynotes gemacht.
Also ich finde ja immer diese kompenden Reaktionen, dass das ja jetzt alles nicht so cool war. Ehrlich gesagt kann ich das nicht ganz nachvollziehen. Weil ich meine, es wird immer gesagt, die Keynote war toll, wenn irgendwie neue Hardware vorgestellt wird.
Aber die Hardware kauft man sich nicht sofort.
Oder ein neues Betriebssystem rediesst wird. Ich meine, das sind nun wirklich die Big Events. Bloß ich fand ja, was sie jetzt softwaremäßig vorgestellt haben, eigentlich ganz schön beeindruckend.
Ich finde dieses Face ist ganz toll, auch wenn alle sagen, dass das mit Picasa schon lange geht.
Geht das mit Picasa schon lange?
Das geht mit Picasa schon lange. Ich habe es gestern auch mal ausprobiert, aber man muss vorher die Bilder hochladen.
Picasa ist die Bildverarbeitung von Google, die gerade heute auch als Macintosh-Version kam, die sich das gehört als Beta.
Selbstverständlich. Ich habe viele begeisterte Stimmen drüber gehört. Ich finde es total scheiße, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Gibt es eigentlich Software von Google, die nicht Beta ist?
Ja, es gibt Aufstellungen darüber. Ich glaube Gmail ist nicht mehr Beta. Die Suche ist nicht Beta. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die nicht Beta sind.
Ein paar Sachen sind Beta. Bei Google ist immer das Beta, wofür sich sozusagen nicht die Hand in Feuer legen, dass es das auch in einem halben Jahr noch gibt.
Und Chrome natürlich. Chrome ist aus der Beta raus.
Aber lass uns mal bei dem Bild-Kram bleiben. Ich hab jetzt mit... Ich hab Picasso runtergeladen, ich hab's vorhin auch mal über meinen Rechner laufen lassen. Dann war dann die Zeit allerdings auch aus. Also ich hab jetzt keinerlei nennenswerten Dings. Aber die haben diese Gesichtserkennungs-Features da mit drin und das läuft genauso wie bei iPhoto.
Also es ist nicht ansatzweise schön. Also ich find's wirklich relativ hässlich, das Programm. Also ich hab erst mal eine ganze Weile gebraucht, bis ich es überhaupt gefunden habe. Man muss also die Möglichkeit, also man kann Gesichter sich anzeigen lassen. Also es gibt so ein Select Photos with Faces-Button.
Ja.
Der macht dann aber nichts weiter als Fotos mit Gesichtern auswählen. Und wie man dann da Namen eingibt oder so was, hab ich keinen blassen Schimmer. Aber auf der Webseite hab ich dann einen Button gefunden, mit dem man dann auch den Person dann Namen zuordnen kann. Und dann hat er auch mit ein bisschen Glück erkannt, er hat auch weitere Fotos davon. Aber wirklich glücklich bin ich...
Ich lad noch nicht meine Fotos überall hoch. Also selbst dann noch mal den Paranoia-Scheiß weglassen. Da müsste ich ja da hunderte von Megabytes irgendwie irgendwo hochladen. Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Aber gut, es gibt ja jetzt Picasso als Desktop-Anwendung. Das verwaltet ja die Bilder lokal.
Also wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob das damit... Also da habe ich keine Möglichkeit dazu gefunden, wie man das machen könnte. Ich habe auch keine Möglichkeit dazu gefunden, wie... also es wird jetzt so an den Bildern, an den Fotos, wird so angezeigt, wenn ihr einen Geotec haben. Ist auch so eine kleine, ich würde mal sagen, so eine Windrose dran. Aber wie man von da aus auf eine Karte kommt, wo das aufgenommen worden ist, habe ich auch noch nicht verstanden.
Also wir halten fest, Gesichtserkennung und Geotegging... Gab's alles schon vorher... .ist die heiße Scheiße gerade, müssen alle einbauen. Apple hat es jetzt auch eingebaut in iPhoto und sie haben es halt gleich sehr ordentlich gemacht. Sage ich jetzt mal nur von dem, was ich in der Keynote gesehen habe, weil die Software gibt es noch nicht. Die gibt es erst Ende Januar.
Genau.
Richtig? Richtig. Und das wird dann noch abzuwarten bleiben, inwieweit das für dich gelungen ist. Das wird sicherlich seine Stolperfallen haben. Ich fand auch die Geotegging-Geschichte wieder sehr schön integriert mit eingeblendeten Karten und der Rückwärtsermittlung von richtigen Orten auf Basis von Geokordinaten. Das heißt, wenn du es in Paris gemacht hast, dann sagt er auch, dass es in Paris ist.
Sogar auf dem Eiffelturm.
Genau, also runtergebrochen auf Sehenswürdigkeiten bzw. überhaupt auch so auf mehreren Ebenen. Also so Welt, Europa, Frankreich, Paris.
Das könnte echt ein tolles Feature werden.
Ja, also vor allem, ich habe in dem Moment so ein bisschen über meinen Fotodatenbestand nachgedacht. Da ist mit GPS jetzt nicht so viel, außer das, was ich mit dem iPhone geschossen habe. Aber wir wissen alle die Bilder, die man so mit dem iPhone geschossen hat.
Auf jeden Fall. Also ich war sehr begeistert von diesem ganzen iPhotozeug. Ich habe mir, ich glaube 2005 oder so, eine GPS-Maus schenken lassen, die aufzeichnen kann. Nur, damit ich die ganze Zeit diese GPS-Maus in der Tasche haben kann und dann meine Fotos im Nachhinein quasi aus den Zeitangaben, da hat man ja Uhrzeit drinne, in der Kamera auch, um die dann zusammenführen zu können, um die dann irgendwie bei Google Maps reinstellen zu können, hat so als Prototyp natürlich irgendwann auch mal funktioniert, aber ist nie so ganz fertig geworden. Aber ich freue mich seit Jahren drauf, wenn Apple dieses Feature endlich mal einbaut und jetzt haben sie es eingebaut. Also eigentlich bin ich glücklich, das ist toll. Das ist bestimmt ein großer Spaß.
Also ich denke auch, das iPhoto ist auf jeden Fall nett. Was ich noch bemerkenswerter fand, sind die Features in iMovie. Also da sieht man, dass sie nicht nur in der Lage sind, eine Software komplett neu zu schreiben, wie sie das ja letztes Jahr gemacht haben mit iMovie 08, wo sie den ganzen alten Core weggeschmissen haben, es nochmal komplett neu aufgesetzt haben und dann natürlich eine ganze Menge der alten Features rausgelassen haben, also insbesondere so Übergänge editieren und so weiter, war einfach nicht mehr so detailliert möglich. Und jetzt haben sie ja total den Overdrive eingeschaltet.
Das hab ich auch gesehen, ja klar.
Also wie man da Überblendungen macht, interaktiv und wie visuell das ist, das war schon sehr schick, also aus der Ferne.
Es hat mir Lust darauf gemacht, endlich mal mit diesem Thema Videobearbeitung anzufangen. Oder ich hab das schon mal so ein bisschen gemacht mit iMovie 08, da fand ich es schon sehr spannend. Hatte aber viele Probleme, insbesondere mit Kameraformaten, weil so diese klassische Mini-DV-Kamera hat ja eh keine Sau mehr, also hat man irgendeinen Fotoapparat rumfliegen. Das hat mich sehr viel Zeit gekostet, einen Fotoapparat zu finden, dessen Format dann auch von iMovie akzeptiert wird, so ohne Probleme. Und da ist es hoffentlich auch mal ein bisschen besser geworden, was aber auch die dann wirklich einen der Mobs aufzeichnen konnte, und MPEG-4 und alles.
Dabei wird sich so einiges entscheiden. Das habe ich jetzt aber auch wenig verfolgt. Na dann ist da so die anderen, warte mal, was war das? iPhoto, iMovie, was war das dritte? GarageBand. Da habe ich ja schon die Daumen gedrückt. Da dachte ich so, ja, neue Podcast-Features, bitte. Na, stattdessen noch mehr Gitarrenmusik. Gut, aber ich finde den Ansatz sehr cool. Also was sie ja gemacht haben, ist, sie haben GarageBand eingehend erweitert, dass sie eben auch Musik lernen.
Was ich mal ganz interessant fand, gab es da schon mal vorher, dass Apple tatsächlich Medieninhalte sozusagen produziert hat? So richtig? Das war's? Na eigentlich, also bisher kannte ich, dass Apple schon aufgehört hat, irgendwann nur Computer zu verkaufen und Betriebssysteme. Klar, daran haben wir uns irgendwann mal gewöhnt. Dann haben sie angefangen, Musik zu verkaufen und Filme zu verkaufen. Aber das ist doch das erste Mal, dass ich das so mitbekomme, dass Apple richtig selber anfängt, Inhalte zu produzieren und zwar in Form von diesen Unterrichtsstunden, die man sich dann dazu kaufen kann.
Naja, das ist halt Verkaufshörder für Garageband. Die müssen das ja irgendwie wollen.
Nee, da würden sie offensichtlich richtig Geld machen, weil die gibt es ja dann für 4,99.
Genau, die Schnupper-Versionen sind umsonst. Wenn du mehr willst, dann musst du zahlen.
Und wenn die da anfangen, irgendwie das Ding rauszubuddeln und den dann vor die Kamera zu setzen und denen dann sagen, guck mal, erzähl mal das und das hier, dann haben die eine richtige Inhalteproduktion quasi plötzlich, was ich so anspannend fand.
Das ist dann irgendwie Rockstar auch nicht mehr so das wahre. Da musst du dann im hohen Alter schon irgendwie so Guitar-Lessons irgendwie produzieren für irgendeine Computer-Furzelbude.
Ja und vor allem musst du das für Sony machen oder für BMG und jetzt machst du das plötzlich für Apple. Find ich schon eine ganz lustige, so eine Entwicklung.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Schritt. Also vor allem, was mich besonders, also was ich besonders cool finde da dran ist, dass sie einfach diese Idee einer Musiksoftware so konsequent weiterdenken. Also dass sie sagen, okay Leute, am Anfang schließen jetzt die Instrumente an, aber dass ja der Macintosh auch immer ein Einsteiger-System ist oder sein kann und dass sie auch vor allem junge Leute ansprechen wollen. Da sitzt halt das Kid irgendwie jetzt mit seiner neuen elektrischen Gitarre zu Hause vor seinem Macintosh, kann das anschließen und dann kann man irgendwie jetzt auch noch die Helden, ja, also bekannte Künstler, keine Ahnung, muss man natürlich dann auch noch mögen, sich für 5 Dollar dazuklicken und dann zeigen die einem, wie man halt irgendwie Musikinstrumente spielt. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was jetzt der eher edukative Wert dieser Kliste ist.
Also ich werd's bestimmt mal ausprobieren. Ich wollt ja schon seit Ewigkeit mal ein bisschen Gitarre lernen. Ich hab mir sogar irgendwann mal bei Real eine Gitarre gekauft, an der ist eine Seite mittlerweile sogar schon gerissen, die muss ich mal reparieren und dann, wenn iLife da ist, dann werd ich mal berichten, wie das so läuft und dann klippern wir hier im Sommer. Und wen lädst du dir runter?
Das Eidachs oder Gitarlessen von dem ACDC-Gitaristen haben wir, Angus Young oder wie er heißt.
Kann ich auf meiner Akustikgitarre dann schön.
Und lädst du dir dann das Ding runter?
Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, ich weiß ja nicht mal, was es da gibt. Erstmal so die Grunde.
Ob's dann auch Deutsche geben wird? Die wirst du dann auch auf Deutsch machen, weil das ist ja nun alles Englisch.
Peter Masall.
Ja, Marius Müller-Wessernhagen.
Oh Gott, Grönemeyer. Da lernt man dann, wie man beim Singen stottert. War nicht so gemeint, wie ich erwartet.
Ich könnte mir, von Grönemeyer hätte ich so ein komplettes Macintosh-Bedientutorial. Das Fenster öffnen. Und klick jetzt drauf. Ja, das wird doch mal was Schönes, Neues.
Ich hoffe auf jeden Fall, dass sie keine Session mit dir machen.
Der Chat schlägt auch Wolfgang Petri vor.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ja, da ist eine Menge drin. Ich sag nur Heino.
Oder hier die Scorpions. Pfeifen mit den Scorpions.
Pfeifen, also so ein neues Pfeif-Interface. Hoch und runter scrollen, das kommt vom Scrollen hinweg, ne? Bei den Scorpions kann man sich auf jeden Fall lernen, wie man sich die Zeit vertreibt, während der Beachball of Death da vor sich hin und dreht.
So, wir sollten mal wieder so ein bisschen dichter werden.
Du hast recht, also halten wir es kurz zusammen. iLife ist an sich ein schönes Update, da sind ein paar nette Sachen drin. iPhoto hätte ich gern, finde ich gut.
Finde ich super.
Ich finde auch gerade diese Face-Geschichte finde ich super, weil ich habe echt immer genau das Problem, man hat immer so 1000 Fotos und dann findet man am Ende sowieso nicht irgendwie mal eben schnell das so. Ist natürlich auch ein totales Familien-Fidget. Kein Wunder, dass er das gleich demonstriert hat mit diesem. Jetzt nehme ich diese vier Personen und direkt die mal in so eine Smart-List und dann habe ich so alle Fotos von jemanden aus meiner Familie. Das war cool, das ist einfach, das sind wirklich die netten und wirklich praktischen Sachen.
Aber ist dir das auch aufgefangen, dass, ich glaube, ist das oder ist euch das aufgefangen, dass Steve andere Sachen ausgewählt hätte als Phil? Also ich glaube bei...
Bist du dir da sicher?
Du glaubst doch nicht, dass das Phil die Keynote gemacht hat, die hat Steve geklickt.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich glaube, ich glaube, so ein bisschen Einfluss hat er darauf selber und ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass Phil irgendwie so ein Foto gezeigt hat. Ja, und das ist dann so ein Familienfoto und man sieht irgendwie vier extrem hübsche Frauen, die offensichtlich alle Models sind auf diesem Foto und was, das war ein Model?
Weil Steve hat sich der Kinder gelesen.
Nee, also ich meine, klar sind das immer Models. Ich bin mir der Tatsache durchaus bewusst. Aber ich habe noch nie bei Steve irgendwie so gedacht, so ganz, also das wirkt immer, also er behauptet wenigstens nicht, dass es seine Familie wäre oder dass es irgendwelche Familienfotos wären oder ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie war da so ein bisschen was, war schon anders, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Ich glaube nicht, dass jemand unterhalb von Steve auch irgendeinen Einfluss hat, das geht gar nicht.
Meinst du nicht? Also ich meine, wenn er die ganze Vorbereitung dann komplett gemacht hätte, dann hätte er ja auch noch die eigentliche Keynote selber halten können. Außer er ist wirklich kränker als er krank tut.
Ich bin auch krank und er kann das halt nicht per Skype machen. Ich habe auch abgenommen übrigens.
Und du wolltest schon heute deine Keynote absagen. Aber wir haben dich trotzdem wieder auf die Bühne geholt.
Die hätten den Steve ja auch so von zu Hause. Ich weiß ja nicht, wo der seinen Weihnachtsstuhl beeinschätzt.
Aus dem Urlaub. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, er braucht auch mal eine Pause. Ich kenne das Gefühl irgendwoher. Auf jeden Fall. Dann kam iWork. Und da habe ich ja auch sehr darauf gehofft, dass sich da signifikant was tut. Ich finde zwar nicht, dass sich signifikant was getan hat, aber zumindest scheint einer meiner größten Schmerzen behoben zu sein. Dieses Numbers macht jetzt so den Eindruck, als ob es vielleicht auch mal funktioniert, so ein bisschen as advertised. Also sie haben insbesondere in diesem Formelbereich eine ganze Menge verbessert. Und ich habe das jetzt mal so mit meinen Spreadsheets, die ich damit gemacht habe in letzter Zeit. Ich habe relativ viel mit Numbers gearbeitet zuletzt. Also jetzt nicht wirklich so heavy shit, weil ich bin eigentlich kein Spreadsheet-Power-User, sondern ich habe vor allem mal versucht, so aus der Einfachheit heraus mal ein paar Sachen einfach selber zu entwickeln, ohne Ahnung davon zu haben. Und da bin ich doch schon bei der ersten Numbers-Version gegen so einige Wände gelaufen.
Also so ganz am Anfang war es richtig problematisch, mit Punkt und Komma konnte man nicht auseinanderhalten, so richtig in der deutschen Version.
Die übliche Lokalisierungsproblematik, dann ist es die Doppelte.
Der erste Version hat mein Rechner total lahm gelegt, da ging irgendwie gar nichts mehr. Ich habe da irgendwie tausend Werte reingepastet und dann stand gleich irgendwie alles.
Furchtbar langsam war das genau. Das haben sie aber so ein bisschen mit diesen Bugfixes, die sie nachgeschoben haben, haben sie schon so einiges abgefangen. Aber es gab auch so Corken, wie es hat mit so ein paar Datumsfunktionen. Also ich teste mal gerne gleich Datumsfunktionen, weil dann hat man nämlich immer gleich, wie du auch schon meintest, so Lokalisierungsprobleme kriegst, dann nämlich immer gleich richtig rein. Vor allem, zumal ich meinen Mac immer so benutze, dass ich halt deutsche Metriken verwende, also ich habe Euro, ein deutsches Datumsformat und so weiter alles eingestellt, aber ich benutze halt meinen Computer trotzdem auf Englisch.
Und hast du dann auch noch die Nummernupformate noch selber angepasst?
Jaja, sicher. Also ich habe halt ein richtiges Dezimalkomma und der Punkt trendet tausender und so weiter. Das ist halt immer genau das, wo ganz viele dieser Programme...
Also das hatte ich früher sogar noch auf amerikanisch eingestellt und dann deutsches Datum und...
Ja, und da gab es auch so einige Probleme. Was aber noch viel schlimmer war, sind einfach manche Sachen einfach scheiße dokumentiert waren. Was weiß ich, da gab es so eine Funktion, die hieß DateDiv, die dir einfach den Abstand in Tagen zwischen zwei Daten...
Hast du das vielleicht einfach mal mit Minus gemacht?
Wie Minus?
Du kannst einfach... Ich erstelle ja seit Wochen und Monaten meinen Stundenzettel mit Numbers. Und dann nehme ich einfach Datum von, Datum bis und dann subtrahiere ich einfach die beiden Felder. Und dann hatte ich den Abstand in Stunden, glaube ich.
Ach so, aber dann kommt es in Stunden raus.
In Stunden, dann musst du es multiplizieren.
Na ja, ich... Gut, ich bin gar kein Experte, aber ich habe halt diese Funktion benutzt, wo man eben sagen kann, wie man es denn gerne hätte in Tagen und so weiter. Und dann steht halt in der Dokumentation, wenn du hinschreibst Anführungsstrich D Anführungsstrich, dann macht das dir in Tagen. So, funktionierte bei mir aber nicht. Und ich habe da 50 mal drauf geguckt und ich habe einfach nicht begriffen, was das Problem war. Wissen wir dann endlich mal einen Spritsheet von jemand anderes, wo er auch diese Funktion benutze, in die Hände fiel und ich sah, was der Unterschied war. Ich habe es halt immer als Großbuchstaben eingegeben und da funktionierte es nicht und er sagte halt nur Syntax Error und es stand auch in Großbuchstaben in der Doku los, es funktionierte eben nur mit kleinen Buchstaben. Also da hatte ich schon so ein Amestos-Moment, so ein bisschen.
Also Numbers war immer hübsch, aber für wirklich ernsthafte Sachen nicht zu gebrauchen oder auch für ansatzweise ernsthafte Sachen nicht. Also ich mache da immer Reportings mit und Stundenzettel und so was, dafür reicht es, aber so für ernsthafte Sachen glaube ich, ging das überhaupt nicht.
Was ich liebe an Numbers ist einfach diese einfache Möglichkeit, die Tabellen einfach nur so groß sein zu lassen, wie man sie braucht. Dass man einfach unten und rechts einfach drum alles zusammenschiebt und da einfach nicht mehr Spalten und Zeilen drin sind, als man eben benötigt.
Überhaupt, also für so grafische Scheiße ist das so viel besser als Excel.
Die Layout-Geschichte, man weiß einfach, wie das droht und wie das ist und so. Das ist, ich habe es auch häufiger mal versucht, mich so mit Wechsel anzufreuen, aber es ist allein dieses Menü, diese Sprache auch, die mit dir redet, wie dieses Programm mit dir redet, das ist so eine Beleidigung, das konnte ich so recht nicht ertragen.
Aber ich fühlte mich nicht so, Apple's, wie sagt man, Kerngeschäft, so ein Numbers-Programm.
Ja, aber es fehlte halt eine Menge und es macht jetzt, ich meine, ich habe jetzt heute mal eine Stunde damit verbracht, mehr nicht, aber es machte so den Eindruck, als ob es irgendwie etwas besser geworden ist.
Das neue Numbers?
Ja.
Gibt es das jetzt schon? Das gibt es jetzt schon.
iWork gibt es sofort, ich habe es mir auch schon quasi jetzt auch mal gekauft, auch weil sie halt Keynote aktualisiert haben und diese iPhone-Applikation gleich mit dabei ist, diese Remote-Geschichte. Ich benutze zwar schon seit längerem Remote-Tool dafür, das Stagehand gibt es im App Store. Das steuert halt das auch fern, ist aber so ein bisschen clumsy, weil da hast du dann so ein Stage-Manager-Programm auf deinem Macintosh, dass du starten musst, dass dann das Keynote für dich startet und das ist halt so ein bisschen von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge. Hat aber jetzt auch nicht schlecht dann funktioniert, muss man sagen. Die Anwendung von Apple habe ich heute mal kurz getestet, kann ich mich noch nicht abschließend zu äußern, also so vom Layout her besser, so wie sie die Notes anzeigen, sinnvoller. Vor allem kein Autoritate, das hat dieses andere Ding, irgendwie was vollkommen bekloppt ist.
Ich dachte, das hätte auch Autorität, das von...
Diese Fernbedienung? Nee, du musst auch richtig in den Optionen sagen, ich will jetzt Landscape oder Dings.
Ah, genau, das wäre nämlich meine erste Frage gewesen.
Bei der Präsentation wackelst du die ganze Zeit mit der Hand hin und her.
Ja, eben.
Das bringt überhaupt nichts. Ich muss auch sagen, ja, aber das ist so mit dem Preview und so weiter, das iPhone ist nicht das richtige Interface für Präsentationen, du brauchst da Knöpfe. Und auf dem Kongress, ich hab mir extra für meinen BlinkNight-Vortrag auf dem Kongress extra nochmal so ein Präsentationssteuer-Tool hier von Logitech gekauft, das hab ich dir letztes Mal schon erzählt, ne? Ah, stimmt, ja. Das hat richtige Knöpfe. Alleine schon deshalb, weil es eben auch, ja, das funktioniert einfach zuverlässig, das ist halt einfach irgendeine 2,4 Gigahertz-Geschichte und das meldet sich als Tastatur an, da musst du halt noch mal so einen Nippel da ins USB reinschieben und dann ist das für ihn wie so eine zusätzlich angeschlossene Tastatur. Das ist so ein bisschen barebones, hat aber den Vorteil, es funktioniert und vor allem, ich muss halt nicht in so einem WLAN sein und auf dem Kongress WLAN zu benutzen, um seine Präsentation zu steuern, ist eine schlechte Idee.
Sollte man seinen eigenen WLAN-Hotspot dabei haben.
Ja, und behaupten, man weiß...
Das ist Frequenz, man tippt sich, da nützt dir deine eigene Station auch nix.
Eben, deswegen hab ich das einfach gleich sein lassen. Aber ich würde sagen, normalerweise, wenn du davon ausgehen kannst, dass dir dein Publikum nicht zu feindlich gesonnen ist, sollte man da schon eine Chance haben.
Ich hab bisher nur Ausschritte von deinem Vortrag da gesehen auf dem Kongress und ich hab draußen gesessen, weil ich nicht reingeschafft hab in den Saal, da hat jemand, wie ich es fand, nicht unpassenden Kommentar gehört. Naja, da hat er aber auch ein bisschen zu viele Keynotes schon geguckt. Du hast sehr stiefhaft geklatscht mit der Fernbedienung in der Hand, so auf dem Handgelenk. Ich hab geklatscht? Ja, klar. Ich glaube, du hast nochmal an allen, die teilgenommen haben, großes Dank geklatscht. Ach so, ich hab mal rausgeklatscht.
Ja, das Team hab ich beklatscht.
Man konnte deine Vorbilder erkennen, sag ich mal. Überhaupt nicht schlimm, aber okay.
Meine Vorbilder?
Dein Vorbild.
Also ich finde Steve Jobs macht schon ganz gute Keynotes, aber ist nicht dein Vorbild.
Du hast so geklatscht wie er. Geht ja auch nicht anders. Man klatscht halt in die Hände beim Klatschen.
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, wie man anders klatschen sollte, wenn man so ein Ding in der Hand hat, aber es ist mir auch gar nicht aufgefallen, dass der so geklatscht hat.
Doch, das war auch das. Guck dir das mal an.
Ich hab gehört, dass du einen Gebrick holst.
Ich hab dich überbackt. Quatsch, das war doch nicht gemüßt.
Wie fandest du denn den Rick Roll, Denis?
Ich hab's ja auch noch nicht gesehen. Ich hab's gehört, aber Fefe hat gesagt, er müsste dich mal auf ein Bier einladen.
Wirklich?
Ja, hat Fefe gesagt. Ja, fand er großartig.
Ja, ich war eigentlich auch ganz froh damit. Es war allerdings bemerkenswert, dass so viele Leute das nicht geschnallt haben.
Echt?
Also ich hatte so den Eindruck.
Ich hab gehört, dass du es bestellt hast.
Na ich hab ja was über Blinkenlights und Stereoscope berichtet. Dann hab ich halt irgendwie so unsere Rekorde aufgelistet, was wir alles so gemacht haben, was also schneller höher weiter war. Und dann hab ich halt noch gesagt, naja und dann haben wir noch so ein Tape von Steve Jobs bekommen, was wir abgespielt haben. Und dann hab ich halt das abgespielt. Aber dann war es halt Never Gonna Give You Up von Rick Astley auf dem Haus, was wir halt da gespielt haben, wo es ja auch so das passende Video auf dem Mio zugibt. Insofern ja auch nichts Neues. Ich musste auch davon ausgehen, dass eigentlich so ein großer Teil meiner Audienz sozusagen schon gespoilert war. Waren sie aber gar nicht so sehr. Ja und dann dachte ich mir so, wenn ich schon Rick Roll zeige, dann kann ich den halt auch gleich selber machen. Hab mir Sonnenbrille ausgepackt und den Rick Astley gemacht.
Okay, ich konnte es nicht lachen. Irgendwo habe ich gelesen, das haben wahrscheinlich viele nicht verstanden, dass Steve Jobs dabei gewesen wäre auf dem Kongress, dadurch, dass du den auf dem Haus eingeblendet hast und davon ein Video gezeigt hast.
Das war mir jetzt auch zu kompliziert. Also Steve Jobs war nicht dabei und der wusste wahrscheinlich von uns nichts und der wollte auch wahrscheinlich nichts von uns wissen.
Deswegen, euch so mager geworden.
Wir haben ihn auch nicht gebraucht und so weiter. Es gibt eine Aufzeichnung auf Parrot Bay in einem schlechten WMV von dem Vortrag. Da sucht ihr einfach nach 25C3 und Stereo Scopo und dann habt ihr das. Naja, aber wir wollen ja jetzt hier nicht über meinen Vortrag reden, sondern wir wollen ja über den Vortrag von Phil das blaue Hemd reden. Ja, Phil das blaue Hemd Schiller und der hat iLife und er hat iWork gezeigt. So und jetzt bleiben wir auch nochmal bei iWork. Also wir haben festgestellt Numbers ist irgendwie besser geworden und Pages und Pages.
Ist scheiße geworden.
Ist auch ein bisschen besser geworden. Also ich bin nicht begeistert. Also bei Keynote die Ergänzung, naja mehr Themes und noch mehr Transitions.
Ja, was sollen sie auch großartig machen?
Na, mir würden da eine Menge Sachen einfallen, die sie da machen können. Also ich will auf jeden Fall bessere Bild-Control haben und das ist halt einfach schwierig. Und was eben auch gerade mit der Fernbedienung bei dem Keynote Remote jetzt bei meinem ersten Test nicht gut ist, wenn du Videos hast in deiner Präsentation. Gibt es einfach relativ wenig Möglichkeiten, diese Videos zu steuern, während sie laufen. Also du kannst zwar gut steuern, dass Objekte erscheinen und wieder verschwinden, aber du kannst nicht die Objekte, während sie aktiv sind, steuern. Ich will halt so ein Video auch anhalten können und weiter machen oder ich will ein Video abbrechen können. So und dann muss diese Software auch da eine Vorstellung davon haben, dass da ein Video läuft. Und Keynote ist sich dem ja eigentlich schon bewusst. Ich meine, ich kann da Thumbnails für auswählen und so weiter und ich kann auch sagen, wo er anfängt und aufhört. Also er weiß, dass da ein Video ist. Aber ich kann nicht sehr viel mehr machen lassen, als dieses Ding starten zu lassen. Ich kann es nicht so ohne weiteres jetzt in verschiedenen Phasen erstmal einblenden und dann in einem zweiten Bild sagen und jetzt starte es, sondern ich kann das sozusagen nur gleichzeitig machen. Und wenn es dann halt läuft, und es kann ja auch sein, dass es ein Video ist, was länger ist und so weiter. Oder wenn ich möchte, dass so ein Video Fullscreen läuft zum Beispiel, da gibt es einfach keine Möglichkeit. Ich würde einfach gerne sagen, hier ist jetzt das Video und in dem Slide erscheint es jetzt als Thumbnail. Und wenn ich dann aber wirklich starte, dann soll es bitte Fullscreen laufen. Geht nicht. Wenn ich es Fullscreen haben will, muss ich es eigentlich Fullscreen auf meine Slide drauf klatschen, woraufhin natürlich das entweder alles überdeckt oder alles unter allem drunter liegt. Und dann hast du so ein Gematsche von verschiedenen Objekten. Also das ist einfach nicht gut.
Du würdest gerne ein Video Fullscreen zeigen.
Ja, und vor allem, wenn du dann später aus deinen Slides ein PDF machen willst, dann willst du auch einfach eine Kontrolle darüber haben, wie jetzt so ein platziertes Video in so einem statischen Format rüberkommt. Sodass du da sozusagen nur eben diesen Thumbnail in einer ordentlichen Größe hast und so weiter. Also das finde ich eigentlich sehr schade, dass es nicht geht, weil das machen sie doch auf ihrer Keynote. Und jetzt zeige ich euch irgendwie ein Video mit dem tollen neuen Power Mac. Und jetzt zeige ich euch irgendwie unsere neue Ad. Da wüsste ich aber wirklich mal gerne, wie sie das da platzieren. Ich meine, okay, geht auch irgendwie. Und sie machen ja eigentlich auch keine Unterbrechung. Aber wenn man jetzt wirklich so einen edukativen Film hat, wo man dann auch mal anhält und sagt, jetzt spule ich noch mal ein bisschen zurück. Genau, so. Zurückspringen geht zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht. Und auch eben dann nicht mit so einer Fernbedienung. Als ich meinen Blink-Lines-Vortrag jetzt mal kurz damit getestet habe, war es auch so, er geht so auf die Slide und wenn dann der Slide mit dem Film kommt, dann rotiert hier ewig irgendwie das Teil und dann startet irgendwie der Film ewig nicht. Und wenn er dann startet, kann ich ihn nicht abbrechen und so weiter. Also keine Ahnung. Ich habe jetzt auch noch kein abschließendes Urteil gebetet, nur vom Keynote-Update war ich persönlich ein bisschen enttäuscht. Beim Pages-Update war ich auch etwas enttäuscht. Da haben sie zwar auch wieder Seams und keine Ahnung, tausende kleine Details und ich habe es noch nicht wirklich getestet. Aber was einfach Pages immer noch fehlt, ist einfach das ganz grundlegende. Die haben einfach ein paar ganz grundlegende Sachen da irgendwie verkackt. Das Einzige, was vielversprechend ist, was ich noch nicht getestet habe, ist die Sache mit der Outline. Das könnte in der Tat hilfreich sein.
Ich würde sagen, das ist doch genau für dich das Richtige.
Ja, ja, das stimmt schon. Gerade so Inhaltsverzeichnisse machen oder überhaupt Struktur haben und auch, sagen wir mal, dass das Programm von dieser Struktur weiß, das ist etwas, was Pages noch total gefehlt hat. Aber was mir generell einfach fehlt, ist einfach vererbbare Formate. So und ich habe es bestimmt schon mal erwähnt.
Also dass man quasi eine Formatvorlage macht und dann ein zweites definiert und dann nur Unterschiede definiert.
Genau, ich will einfach da eine Vererbung drin haben. Weil so funktioniert das. Und so funktioniert das aber nicht in Pages. Sondern du hast da ein ewiges Gelumpe und wenn du dann halt so ein blödes Theme nimmst, wo dann so diese ganzen fancy Styles drin sind und so und du willst das irgendwie verändern, dann ist das einfach ein widerlicher Morast und du klickst da irgendwie drin rum und du weißt dann aber auch wirklich nicht mehr wo, wie jetzt noch welches Format mit drin hängt und dann sind die alle irgendwie auch noch so komisch formatiert in diesem bekloppten Zeitbar und es hat einfach alles keine Struktur. Und das ging einfach alles vor 20 Jahren schon viel besser. Habe ich schon mal geheult hier wegen Framemaker? Bestimmt, oder?
Gab es denn jemand für Mac? Ja, also habe ich nie mit jemand gearbeitet.
Ich habe 1900 und was haben wir jetzt?
Davos am Klondike.
Ja, Davos im Klondike irgendwie. Nee, ist noch keine 20 Jahre her, aber 1990 habe ich damit gearbeitet. 1990 habe ich auf dem Macintosh 2 CI 100-seitige Dokumentationen geschrieben. 100-seitige. Stell dir mal ein 100-seitenlanges Dokument auf Pages vor, was für ein Spaß das da ist, durchzuscrollen. Das lief auf dem 2 CI in einer Berserker Geschwindigkeit und ich habe da Bilder drin gehabt und ich habe da irgendwie eine voll mit Vererbung arbeitende Formatvorlage gehabt und ich konnte die Formatvorlage in einer eigenen Datei abspeichern und sie für alle anderen Dokumente sharen und so weiter. Nicht irgendwie, wie es dann Word später eingeführt hat, so mit ins Dokument reinpacken und dann musst du irgendwie so Templates machen und wenn du dann später deine Formatvorlage für 20 Dokumente änderst, dann musst du dir überall wieder irgendwie von Hand und das ist einfach...
Ist das die berühmte Normal.dot?
Was?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Das allererste Word, was ich in der Hand hatte, das Word 3.0, was noch so mit ohne Windows war, das war eigentlich ein ganz gutes Programm. Und Fraymaker war aber schon immer besser. Und irgendwann ist halt Fraymaker von Adobe gekauft worden und sie haben halt die Macintosh-Version gedroppt bis heute. Und Fraymaker ist zwar, wenn du das jetzt öffnest und jetzt sagen wir mal mit so einem neuzeitlichen EP da rangehst nach 15 Jahren, ist das schon alte Software. Da guckst du in die Menüs und die rollen sich so ein bisschen die Fußnägel hoch, weil sie es einfach, weil sie den Fehler gemacht haben, diese Software nicht konsequent auch im User-Interface zu verbessern. Sie haben immer so, ja, unsere Leute kennen das, aber so und so weiter. Wir haben große Customer, so wie sich Quarq Express einfach über lange Zeit nicht verändert hat. So ist es bei Fraymaker auch gewesen, bis dann irgendwie Adobe aus welchen Gründen auch immer beschlossen hat, dass auf Mac Fraymaker keine Rolle mehr spielt. Was meiner Meinung nach ein ganz großer Fehler war von Adobe, es mag für sie wirklich keine große Rolle gespielt haben, das kann ja sehen, aber so Business-Leute gucken einfach anders drauf. Ich denke, das wäre schon sehr wichtig gewesen, dieses Tool auch zu entwickeln. Dann war immer meine große Hoffnung, dass das quasi bedeutet, dass sie InDesign, dass sie das Fraymaker-Team nehmen und ein InDesign setzen und das InDesign sozusagen Fraymaker-Fitures einbauen, aber das passierte halt nie. Und am Ende hatte ich halt einfach nichts mehr. Und jetzt dachte ich, und Word, bei aller Liebe, das mögen viele Leute benutzen, aber für mich ist Word einfach ein stinkender Haufen Müll. Das ist nicht benutzbar und das geht einfach nicht. Dann kam dieses Pages raus und ich dachte mir so, ah, endlich, die Sonne geht auf. Hab mir das dann angeschaut und es war auch furchtbar.
Also ein Pages, wo ich aber auch keine Bücher schreiben wollen. Ich glaube, das ist so das Ding, mit dem macht man mal die Einladungskarte für, damit man mal wieder seinen Farbdrucker nutzen kann.
Ja, aber sogar das Schreiben von normalen Briefen, finde ich, ist eine Zumutung. Also klar, wenn man sich so aufwendig so ein Template macht, aber man macht ja erst mal so ein Template. Kannst du das nicht gut ausrichten? Okay, also vielleicht übertreibe ich jetzt so ein bisschen, aber ich finde, man hätte das einfach geschmeidiger machen können. Vor allem muss eine Formatvorlage, muss einfach auf eine Vererbung basieren, dass das einfach eine Erkenntnis, die hätte man schon vor 20 Jahren haben können.
Also ich habe bei Pages immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass so das Programm, wenn man da so eine Standardvorlage nimmt und wenn man da nicht so hohe Ansprüche an die Individualisierung stellt, eigentlich sehr Mac-untypisch, klar, aber dann kann man damit, glaube ich, relativ schnell okaye Ergebnisse entkriegen.
Ja, aber ich habe ja keinen Mac, um okaye Ergebnisse zu erzielen bei dem, was ich tue, sondern ich habe mir einen Mac-Touch gekauft, um einfach mal amtliche Ergebnisse erzielen zu können.
Was mir aber aufgefallen ist, das ist in einer Kino, dass das auch erwähnt worden, ansonsten wüsste ich es noch nicht mal, dass es jetzt was gibt und zwar linked charts in Numbers und Pages.
Hast du das auch gesehen, Denis? Bist du überhaupt noch da?
Ich bin auch da, ja, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Das ist so ein Feature, dass man in Numbers einen Chart macht und dann ist es in Pages drin und wenn man es in Numbers ändert, ändert sich das in Pages mit.
Und wo gab es das wohl das erste Mal?
Das erinnert mich doch verdammt an System 7 unter dem Namen Publish and Subscribe.
Absolut, genau daran musste ich nämlich auch denken. Und hast du das mal ausprobiert?
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe damals viel rumgespielt mit Publish and Subscribe.
Ach so, damals. Ja, damals hatte ich damals extrem viel.
Ich dachte, dass ich also für mich Publish and Subscribe auf System 7 war einfach mal wir reden hier von Mac OS. Mac OS Version 7, 19 und 90 war es glaube ich auch.
Aber bei 95 kam 7.5 raus.
Publish and Subscribe war ein 7.5. Nee, oder was ein 7.0?
Publish and Subscribe war ein 7.0. Das war im Inside Macintosh Band 6 wurde das beschrieben.
Und das war so großartig. Also das hat richtig funktioniert. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, welche Programme, also Rectime konnte das damals.
Rectime hat das natürlich unterstützt. Rectime war damals sowieso ein tolles Programm, wenn wir jetzt ja schon bei Textverarbeitung und so was sind. Ist es bis heute glaube ich, wenn es nicht so sagenhaft teuer wäre.
Das gibt es noch.
Das ist nicht sagenhaft teuer. Erstens gibt es das noch und zweitens ist es kostenlos soweit ich weiß.
Nee, die kostenlose Version haben sie leider irgendwann wieder abgeschafft, dieses Rectime Privat.
Bist du sicher?
Ja, weil ich nämlich neulich Rectime genau darunterladen wollte. Also Verkauf ist...
Ich kann ja noch mal kurz was für einen Publisher-Subscribe sagen. Das war...
30 Tage Demo-Version gibt es davon.
Und der Preis ist wirklich, Preisliste Rectime, Normalpreis...
Ich höre gerade nicht.
In der S-Version 867 Euro. 867 Euro.
867 Euro?
Inklusive Mehrwertsteuer. Das ist die S-Version.
Das ist Steuer, weil ich sehe was von 695. Ach so, Dollar. Ja, die nimmst auch von den Lebenden.
Na gut, ich meine, wenn eine Software Sachen gut macht und es auch seinen Kunden findet, dann ist das ja auch irgendwie in Ordnung.
Was kostet eigentlich ein Photoshop heutzutage?
Auch zu viel.
Ich meine, es gibt ja mittlerweile nur noch in diesem Mega-Bundles. Ja, aber zurück zu dem Feature Publishing Subscribe und warum ich auch genauso grinsen musste, wie du, als ich gesehen habe, mit Wir haben jetzt hier so Live-Link. Das war halt ein Feature des Betriebssystems. Genau, man konnte einfach irgendwelche Daten sagen, hallo, ich möchte gerne notifiziert werden, wenn sich hier etwas ändert. So lief das und das funktionierte sogar über Fileserver-Grenzen hinweg. Ich konnte ein Dokument auf dem Server mit dem einen Computer abspeichern oder ändern und sozusagen da wieder reinschreiben. Und dann ging das eben über die Events, über das AFP, hinüber, auch über so Local Talk, damals ja sozusagen noch HIP, kriegte halt das laufende Programm auf dem anderen Rechner ein Event geliefert, so nach dem Motto, diese Datei, die du abonniert hast, diese Datei, die du beobachtest, die hat sich geändert, lade die doch mal neu. Das hat richtig gut funktioniert.
Und das Geilste war, das Programm musste nicht mehr wissen, was es da darstellt. Das hat irgendwie so, ich krieg jetzt hier gerade irgendwie sowas wie ein Bild geliefert oder ich krieg hier gerade einen Ton geliefert. Und das wusste ich noch mit Mühe und Not, aber ob das jetzt ein Grafik ist oder ob das ein Text ist oder wie auch immer.
Das war bestimmt die Hölle, das zu programmieren. Aber wie auch immer. Also auf jeden Fall, daran musste ich auch denken. Jetzt haben sie sowas wieder eingebaut, aber ich vermisse immer noch die entsprechende Betriebssitzung.
Irgendjemand hat das irgendwann, hat das mal ein Open-Source-Entwickler, ich weiß leider nicht mehr, wie es hieß, ist es leider auch komplett untergegangen, hat auch mal gesagt, Publish and Subscribe war super, wir machen das jetzt mal hier.
Omni Group war das, glaube ich, die sich mit anderen geeinigt haben auf so ein Framework. Ich habe jetzt aber auch gerade vergessen, wie es heißt.
Genau, die haben dann sowas probiert, ein Apple vorbei zu entwickeln, was aber glaube ich, sagen wir mal, in die Hose gegangen ist. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe nie wieder was davon gehört.
Wie ist denn das nochmal gleich?
Und ich habe ja so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass Apple das jetzt mal die Gelegenheit nutzt und das jetzt erstmal ein iWork einbaut, um dann vielleicht Erfahrungen zu sammeln. Wie kriegt man denn sowas auf die Betriebssystem-Ebene gehilft?
Ich denke, der Bedarf ist einfach zu gering. Also es ist einfach, dieses Placement findet zu selten wirklich auf eine Art und Weise statt, dass es sinnvoll in ein System-Framework integrieren lässt. Ich glaube, das ist der Hauptgrund. Du hast solche Sachen heute innerhalb von dieser Paketzoftware, also Adobe macht das sozusagen mit sich und so.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile hätte man auch eigentlich die perfekte Quelle für solche Informationen und zwar das Web. Also eigentlich könnte man noch so geile Sachen machen wie, ich weiß, das geht alles theoretisch über XML, RPC und WSDL und so und wie es nicht alles heißt, der ganze Scheißdreck, aber benutzen kann es ja doch keiner, dass sie sich mal was ausdenken und jetzt fällt mir natürlich erstmal wirklich nicht viel mehr ein als Wetterbericht und Börsenkurse, aber dass ich ein Pages-Dokument habe und dass mir immer die aktuellen Wetterdaten automatisch rein geladen werden von irgendwo her und dann mit Numbers schön dargestellt werden als Grafiken und die dann direkt mein Pages-Dokument reingehen oder weiß ja teufel was.
Also ich glaube, da gibt es schon Möglichkeiten. Was uns zu iwork.com bringt, was so zwar nicht jetzt genau das tut, aber theoretisch tun könnte. Eigentlich hätte ich ja erwartet, so wenn dann jemand was auf iwork.com an meinem Dokument ändert, dann ändert sich das halt auch gleich auf meinem Rechner, während ich auf dasselbe Dokument anschaue.
Also ich habe noch einiges erwartet. Ich habe zum Beispiel erwartet, dass es da ein Button gibt, wo man das nicht mit downloadet, sondern wo ich dann einfach einen Button habe, wo ich drauf drücke, dann kann die andere Person das in ihrem iwork öffnen und dass man dann parallel daran arbeiten könnte.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Was macht es? Man kann seine Dokumente hochladen, das geht relativ easy und dann können andere Leute das reviewn und so Annotations dran machen. Und das ist ja eigentlich schon eine extrem praktische Sache, weil in 99 Prozent der Fälle ist das genau der Grund, warum du überhaupt irgendwie ein Dokument auf Reisen schicken lässt.
Auf Reisen schicken lässt.
Arbeiten kann man noch nicht so richtig, oder? Die können halt nur Notations machen und nicht Inhalte ändern.
Nee, die können kein Inhalt ändern.
Hab ich auch so verstanden, dass es nicht geht.
Ich habe verstanden, angucken und Anmerkungen machen.
Anmerkung ist ja nicht Inhalt.
Genau.
Sobise erhält er erst mal noch keine Konkurrenz für dich.
Ja, das ist schon noch eine andere Geschichte. Ich bin gespannt. Ich meine, viele Dinge bei iWork fehlen mir noch. Also warum gibt es nur eine Keynote-Fernbedienung auf dem iPhone? Wieso kann ich nicht auf meinem iPhone meine Keynote-Präsentationen auch zeigen? Das Ding hat einen Videousgang. Ist das auch ein großes Bildschirm irgendwie? Ja, aber ist das dann interaktiv?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ist das doch mit Quicktime? Ist da eine gewisse Interaktivität drin, dass man so rumklickern kann und so? Das müsste man mal versuchen, glaube ich.
Aber sicherlich nicht in dem gleichen Maße. Bestimmt nicht.
Aber iLife kann jetzt schön fürs iPhone exportieren. Da haben sie ja hundertmal drauf hingewiesen, dass die ganzen Präsentationen, die man macht, in i...
Das sind diese Fotos, Slideshows und so.
Genau. Und da sind wir gar nicht drauf eingegangen, die teilweise ziemlich schick aussahen, fand ich. Dieser Pseudo-3D-Effekt da so, wo er dann seine Farben zerlegt hat.
Wo er die einzelnen Kanäle irgendwie separat rotiert.
Genau. Das fand ich eigentlich, das fand ich ziemlich sexy.
Wie kommt ihr aus iPhone? Gibt es eine neue iPhone-Version, die bald kommen wird oder habe ich nämlich nicht richtig aufgesucht?
Ich hab da weggehört gerade in dem Moment, deswegen weiß ich das nicht so genau.
Ich bilde mir an, dass er dazu gar nicht so viel gesagt hat. Ich vermute aber einfach mal, dass wir einen Quicktime-Film draus machen werden und den dann in iTunes reinpacken. Und dann ist es beim nächsten Synchronisieren einfach irgendwann in den Videos drin.
Verstehe.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Könnte sein. Geht ja mit Keynote auch, ne?
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht war das ja schon im 2.2-Update drin und es wurde erst am 7. Januar freigeschaltet, das Feature oder so.
Oder wird erst.
iLife, iWork, ich glaube, das können wir jetzt abhaken, oder? Haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen? Bestimmt, aber...
Aber es gibt neue... Es gibt noch was Neues von der Keynote.
One more thing. Nein, erst mal nicht One more thing, erst mal Nummer 3.
Erst mal Nummer 3.
Es gibt jetzt endlich Akkus, die man nicht mehr wechseln kann.
In sehr, sehr großen Laptops.
In sehr, sehr großen Laptops, die jetzt an sich erst mal so keine Überraschungen sind, weil das war ja klar.
Und man zahlt 50 Dollar mehr für Matt.
Und nicht schwarz. Meine persönliche Schätzung, habe ich heute auch schon auf Twitter bekanntgegeben, ist ja, dass irgendwie der Anteil der Matten so bei 0,01 Prozent liegen wird.
Wobei Phil in der Keynote gesagt hat, dass der Bedarf ziemlich groß sei.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass er bestimmt Hälfte, Hälfte.
Also mit dem ziemlich groß. Also, er hat gesagt, wir haben...
Für 0,01 Prozent hätten sie es nicht gemacht.
Na, sie haben da einfach einen extrem wichtigen Markt und das ist der Publishing- und Creative-Markt. Die 17 Zoller werden einfach viel von solchen Grafikern benutzt.
Videoschnitt wahrscheinlich auch.
Und Photoshop und diesen ganzen Kram. Videoschnitt, ja, mag auch sein. Klar.
Und insofern? Das wären bestimmt schon ein paar Leute kaufen.
Ich glaube auch, die ganzen Grafik-Clickies, die wollen dieses... Wie heißt das? Was habe ich hier? Dieses Glossier finden die alle voll doof. Verstehe ich zwar nicht, aber ist bei denen so.
Die sind auch ein bisschen konservativ. Grafiker?
Nee, die kriegen halt die Krise, wenn sich da drin was spiegelt. Aber ich kriege halt die Krise, wenn meine Farbe nicht so satt ist, wie sie halt sein müsste.
Naja, vielleicht liege ich ja auch falsch. Da ist es mir auch dann eigentlich egal. Tatsache ist, das Ding hat keinen wechselbaren Akku. Und ich muss sagen, it's about time.
Ich habe gerade, neben der neuen Festplatte für mein MacBook, habe ich das erwähnt, ich habe mir eine neue Festplatte eigentlich gegönnt vor Weihnachten. Eine 500 Gigabyte-Platte.
Hast du jetzt auch die 100 Gigabyte Free Space Rule?
Ne, bisher noch nicht. Dass du immer 100 Gigabyte frei sein musst.
Ja, kann ich dir sehr empfehlen. Mach entspanntes Arbeiten.
Also bisher habe ich noch knapp 300 frei. Insofern, da ist noch, da ist noch. Und ich habe schon wirklich, ich habe schon verschwendet.
Die Torrens laufen schon.
Ich habe Windows 7 runtergeladen und habe Windows 7 parallel in einer Vmware installiert. Also ich wirklich so, wie kriege ich den Platz weg? Und es wird nicht weniger.
Windows 7. Da fällt mir einfach dieser Film 7 ein. Dir auch?
Und am Ende sind alle tot. Ich kann nicht gern ein bisschen dazu erzählen, ich finde es nämlich gar nicht so schlecht. Also ich werde jetzt nicht wechseln. Nein, nein, nein, wir können gleich gerne noch ein neues Laptop machen. Bei der Gelegenheit habe ich mir einen neuen Akku gekauft, weil der alte einfach durch war. Womit sich jetzt meine Theorie zu dem Thema ja eigentlich komplett geändert haben müsste. Aber ich sage trotzdem auch, drauf geschissen. Wenn die das wirklich mit dem Akku-Management halbwegs hinkriegen, dann soll der ruhig fast eingebaut sein.
Es soll ja auch dreimal so lange halten. Dann musst du halt deinen Akku nicht sofort tauschen. Und man kann ihn ja tauschen. Das ist ja nicht so, dass man ihn nicht tauschen kann. Man kann ihn bloß nicht selber tauschen.
Ich meine, 170 Dollar kostet das. Das heißt, das wären so um die 150 Euro sein. Ja, das ist ein Witz. So ein Akku kostet auch 130 Euro. Und ob ich nun daneben stehe und kurz warte, bis sie das Ding auf und wieder zugeschraubt haben, wenn ich dafür 3 Stunden oder 40 Prozent längere Akkulaufleistung habe? Hey, dann stell ich mich mal auf 5 Minuten daneben. Und wir nehmen den Akku auswechseln.
So ein Akku wechseln, das ist ja wirklich eine der metrosexuellsten Tätigkeiten, die man in seinem Computer ausführen kann. Da muss man seine Münze da irgendwie drehen. Und dann schiebt sich das Ding da so schäbig irgendwie aus dem Rechner raus. Und man weiß schon, das sind einfach alles Sollbruchstellen und Wackelelemente. Auch dieser Deckel, den du bei den neuen Dingern abnimmst.
Voll dünne Scheiße.
Voll dünne Scheiße. Also da habe ich wirklich schon stabilere... Ich meine, das tut der Struktur des Rechners nicht wirklich abbruch, aber...
Das 17 Zoll, das ist jetzt wirklich Judy-Buddy, so wie man es haben will.
Damit werden wahrscheinlich demnächst Banken überfallen. Mehrere Täter mit 17 Zoll MacBook Pros schlugen sich hier.
Wenn man die so vor sich halten kann und die Patronen nicht durchgehen.
Links, rechts irgendwie, haust du die Kunden weg und bist sofort am Bankschalter. Keine Chance. Ja, und dann schießen die irgendwie.
Sag das Schäuble.
Dann schießen die die Sondereinsatzkommandos scharf. Genau, und dann so voll Matrix-Style. Einfach so leicht nach hinten fallen mit 3D-Kamera, so das 17 Zoll. Und dann erschießt du sie alle mit den Rückschlägern.
Und wenn es dann kalt ist, dann schaltest du noch die zweite Grafikkarte ein, damit du einen schönen, warmen Rechner hast.
Ein universelles Gerät. Aber ich werde es mir nicht kaufen. Und ich werde mir jetzt aber auch die anderen nicht kaufen, bevor da auch eine nicht auswechselbare Akku drin ist. Weil, wenn ich eins mal richtig geil finde, 8 Stunden, 8 Stunden soll das Ding halten. Das heißt, es hält wahrscheinlich tatsächlich wirklich 6.
Oder? Aber das ist okay.
Ja, aber die hältst du dann aber auch 6.
Ja, 6 Stunden.
Die aktuellen ja höchstens kommt es auch auf, auf was kommst du denn, dreieinhalb oder sowas, oder?
6 Stunden, da kannst du sogar im ICE 1 von Berlin nach München fahren mit.
Oder Köln.
Oder Köln. Ich meine, da fährt, glaube ich, mittlerweile kein ICE 1 mehr, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Man hat einfach jetzt genug Zeit, da irgendwo anzukommen.
Und was ich ja noch als Entwertungskriterium finde, für dieses ganze Akku austauschen, bis der überhaupt erstmal so ein fest eingebaute Akku so wenig Kapazität hat, dass er nur noch so lange hält, wie so ein alter Akku überhaupt mal gehalten hat, dass man ihn mal auswechseln wollte überhaupt, vergehen ja auch schon mal ein paar Jahre. Nach zwei Jahren hat man dann eigentlich die Akkulaufzeit, die man von Anfang an gehabt hätte, wenn man einen auswechselbaren Akku gehabt hätte.
Ich finde, das macht alles total Sinn und ich finde jetzt diese Aufregerei mit, oh Gott, man kann den Akku nicht wechseln, das klingt so echt so wie, ich will meine Floppy-Disc wieder haben.
Und wenn da nicht irgendwas komplett schief geht, dann können wir glaube ich alle fest damit rechnen, dass wir in spätestens zwei Jahren Würz von Apple keine Geräte mehr geben, die auswechselbare Akkus haben.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn jetzt wirklich einer länger durchhalten will, dann muss er sich einfach noch ein zweites 17 Zoll dazukaufen, was einfach als Ersatzgerät in der Tasche wird.
Was nach dem Banküberfall auch kein Problem sein sollte.
Scheiße wird zu Apple nur, wenn sie einen Batterie-Rückruf machen müssen. Wahrscheinlich haben sie deswegen auch mit dem 17 Zoll angefangen, weil davon kaufen sie wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so viele und dann ist der Rückruf nicht so toll.
Das denke ich allerdings auch, dass das erstmal so ein Qualitätstest-Bett ist, dass wir mal schauen, wobei wenn ich mich nicht verlesen habe, auch im R, was ja auch schon ein nicht wechselbarer Akku ist, ist ein Lithium-Polymer-Akku drin.
Genau, der gleiche neue Akku-Typ.
Genau, überhaupt hatten sie alles sozusagen schon im R, haben da aber nie drüber geredet, was da schon alles so toll ist, Unibody und so weiter, hätten wir auch echt mal selber drauf kommen können, ehrlich gesagt. Und auch jetzt dieser Akku, was weiß ich, was sie in diesem R noch revolutionär ist, alles schon längst seit einiger Zeit verwenden, was erst jetzt auf weiteren Special Events vorgestellt wird. Wie gesagt, der GPS, das kommt doch noch. Und jetzt wollen sie es nämlich auch alle haben. Jetzt wo iPhoto... iPhoto hat jetzt irgendwie voll GPS-Support. Jetzt schreien die alle danach, dass sie das wollen, dass irgendwie alle haben.
Du machst doch mit deinem iPhoto nicht direkt das Bild, sondern mit der Kamera. Okay, mit dem EyeSight-Halter, na gut.
Ja, mit der EyeSight kannst du auch Fotos machen. Nee, ich will auch einfach, ich will einfach, dass mein Computer weiß, wo er ist. Ja, mein Telefon weiß das ja auch. Warum sollte mein Computer dümmer sein als mein Telefon? Wo kommen wir denn da hin? Das waren sich die drei Sachen. Und dann Nummer 4, die große Überraschung, die auch keine war, weil das ja eigentlich auch schon seit längerer Zeit bekannt war, iTunes mit ohne DM.
Jetzt stehen sie ja toll da. Wie ist denn das? Gibt es dann kein DM mehr? Schaffen sie das jetzt ab? Es gab ja vorher dieses iTunes Plus, da muss man ja ein bisschen mehr für zahlen.
Das gibt es aber immer noch. Das ist ja sozusagen das mit ohne DM.
Den Mehrpreis haben sie wieder weggenommen. Die kosten jetzt auch den gleichen Preis, wie die normalen.
Jetzt müsste ich theoretisch meine bereits gekaufte Musik schon upgraden können. Da muss ich mal rauskriegen, wie das geht.
Das kannst du auch. Dann musst du in den iTunes Store gehen und dann wird da rechts oben, da musst du dich auch ein bisschen suchen, Aktualisierungen angeboten. Der Witz ist, dass es ja nicht dein iTunes zuhause ist, was sich deine Musik anschaut und dir dann sagt, was es neu gibt. Sondern es ist der iTunes Store, der tatsächlich in deine Verkaufshistorie reinschaut.
Meine Bibliothek aktualisieren? Da ist er, der Link.
Exakt. Dann kriegst du auch gleich einen schönen Preis. Wie viel hast du denn so gekauft?
Es sind 40 Songs, die er mir anbietet. Wow, 30,57 Euro.
Wirklich?
Für 143 Titel insgesamt.
Okay, so hart ich nicht.
30 Titel, neun Alben.
Da musst du das jetzt mal so teilen und mal gucken, ob dir das wert ist. Danach hast du es in besserer Qualität. Ohne DRM.
Kann ich denn auch, ich musste auch nur einen Teil nachkaufen können, oder? Wahrscheinlich, indem ich jetzt hier so...
Kannst du da wahrscheinlich auch tun.
Aber Jungs, ne, ihr könnt die Songs natürlich dann trotzdem nicht auf Pirate Bay werfen, weil in den Metadaten immer noch irgendwie so eure Kundennummer, sonst wie Zeug, so drin steht. Gibt es in der aktuellen Datenschleuder, wenn die dann noch aktuell ist, wenn nicht in der letzten, gibt es einen Artikel dazu.
Genau, das hat man aber damals schon relativ einfach bei dem alten iTunes Plus mit Strings rausbekommen, dass da irgendwo die E-Mail-Adresse direkt drin steht.
Ja, da gibt es auch ein Tool, mit dem kann man es auch dann wieder wegmachen, aber sollte man nicht vergessen, dass schon die eigenen Daten da irgendwie noch eingebettet sind. Auch wenn man den entdeckt.
Außerdem sollte man sowieso keine Musik über Pirate Bay austauschen, außer man braucht...
Doch, ich finde schon, dass man Musik über Pirate Bay austauschen sollte, solange das bei anderen Kanälen so schwierig ist.
Bei Musik geht es ja gerade mittlerweile wirklich. Muss man ja echt sagen, oder?
Was geht wirklich?
Naja, ich meine, das ist in iTunes Musik zu kaufen, das ist jetzt auch nicht so viel komplizierter, als auf so Pirate Bay etwas runterzuladen.
Das ist viel einfacher. Ich habe jetzt schon Musik gekauft, seitdem. Ich habe mir immer gesagt, ich kaufe da... Also ich habe ein paar Sachen gekauft, ich habe nur Sachen gekauft, wo ich eben auch, sagen wir mal, über andere Quellen nicht so schnell fündig wurde, wo ich einfach was mal benötigt habe für irgendwas. Und diese Sachen, das weiß ich, ich habe so mal so Lieder verschenkt, habe ich dann einfach auf CD gebrannt, dann sind die sozusagen auch mit ohne DHM, das war dann unproblematisch. Ja, und jetzt habe ich auch gleich mal so als Dankeschön, habe ich gleich noch mal ein Album gekauft. Mozart, übrigens. Ja, und was musst du bezahlen? Achso, 30 Euro, hast du gesagt.
30 Euro, ja, und ich habe keine Möglichkeit, irgendwelche Teile davon wegzulassen?
Denk nicht nach, da ist ein großer Button, da steht drauf Kaufen. Kaufen, kaufen, kaufen. Das ist alles, worum es geht. Es ist Weihnachten gewesen.
Ja, ich hab mir einen neuen Festplatt, ich hab mir einen neuen Akku gekauft, ich hab mir ein iPhone gekauft, ich weiß nicht, ob die so 30 Euro...
Du hast 300 Gigabyte frei.
Aber keine 30 Euro frei.
Für 30 Euro hast du bestimmt gleich mit der Aktualisierung deiner Bibliothek zumindest schon mal so das eine oder andere Gigabyte auf der Seite.
Wie viel Provision kriegst du eigentlich?
Das wird mir immer nachgesagt. Ich appelliere einfach nur an deine Glückseligkeit als Konsument.
Aber ich will gar nicht alles kaufen. Ich würde einen Teil davon wirklich gerne... Ach, leck mich doch! Ich wieder stehe. Nee, ich klicke nicht. Ich bin gerade mit dem Stuhl zurückgefolgt.
Das macht gerade meine Aura aus. Er findet es wohl etwas bedrohlich, dass ich hier mit dem Zauberstab in der Hand auf dem Tisch stehe und mit Wallen im Gewand auf ihn einrede. Ja, also auch hier gibt es wieder nicht viel zu sagen. Außer, es hat stattgefunden, ist an sich eine gute Sache. Ich meine, sie sind natürlich jetzt dabei und behaupten, ja, jetzt haben wir kein DAM. Das stimmt natürlich. Für Musik, für Filme mitnichten. Bei Filmen ist alles voll.
Nicht nur bei Filmen, sondern auch bei Programmen.
Ja, aber das hat man wirklich schon mehrfach ausführlich.
Nee, aber ich finde es lustig, dass sich jahrelang als Vorreiter in so, wir kämpfen gegen DAM und jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Plötzlich sieht man, ja, okay, wie du bereits sagtest, bei Musik nicht, aber ansonsten überall. Aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen, aber trotzdem.
Ja, aber ich finde, dass Musik eben auch ein bisschen was anderes ist als Filme. Also die Art und Weise, wie du Musik konsumierst, ist anders. Musik hörst du immer wieder, überall, an verschiedensten Orten, mit unterschiedlichen Geräten. Kann man natürlich jetzt mit Einschränkungen auch bei Filmen sagen, aber mehr ehrlich, wie oft guckst du dir Spielfilme an?
Ein, zwei Mal, wenn es hochkommt.
Wie viele Filme hast du zu Hause original gekauft, die rumstehen?
Ähm, ich?
Ja, zum Beispiel, beide.
Ich habe hier so eine Postkiste voll GVDs.
Wie viele?
Ah, keine Ahnung. 30, 40.
Und wie oft guckst du die?
Naja, halt nie.
Du hast die Kubrick-Reihe, ich erinnere mich.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich habe mir in meinem Leben exakt noch nie, doch, ich habe mir meine DVD, ich habe ja, per Analyse Galaxis habe ich auf DVD, habe es mir aber auch noch nie angeguckt. Ansonsten habe ich mir noch nie eine DVD gekauft. Ich habe mir öfters mal welche ausgeliehen.
Ich finde es einfach zu unhandlich.
Ich meine, hast du mal so einen ordentlichen Blu-ray-Rip runtergeladen. Das ist einfach viel besser. Ich habe mir nur die Matrix gekauft damals, um meinen DVD-Player in meinem Mac zu testen, weil sonst hatte er noch niemand DVD-Player. Anon ist eine 100, keine Ahnung, 98. Und dann habe ich mir noch Lost Highway gekauft, weil das ist mein Lieblingsfilm. Und die anderen drei DVDs, die ich habe, habe ich geschenkt bekommen, weil jemand eine Amazon-Fehllieferung bekommen hat. Und der hatte die doppelt.
Ja, also ich habe eigentlich auch nur Filme gekauft, die für mich jetzt so totale Evergreens sind. Also wo ich auch, sagen wir mal, so ein gewisses Regalinteresse habe, so wie man bestimmte Bücher im Regal stehen hat. Also wo man einfach sicherstellen will, egal wie einem gerade die eigenen Backups weggeschmolzen sind, dass man das eben auch hat. Da hat einfach so eine Scheibe mit gebrannten Löchern einfach da eine Qualität, die eben so eine Festplatte nicht hat.
Ja, aber Filme sind doch so groß, dass man kleine Kinder hin und her zerstört werden kann. Also Filme werden dir nicht unterm Arsch verschwinden. Ist ja nicht dein eigen erstellter Content, sondern von fremden Leuten erstellter Content und den wird es ja auch immer wieder geben.
So einfach ist es nicht. Also erstmal so bestimmte Versionen sind nicht unbedingt immer so ohne weiteres zu kriegen. Und hier diese Criterion Edition, die du eben auch schon angesprochen hast. Das war die Kubrick. War das auch die Criterion? Nee, von Brasil hab ich. Criterion Edition, das ist so eine Sonderauflage von so Filmspezies. Und die bringen das immer besonders aufbereitet raus. Also im Fall von Brasil sind das 3 DVDs. Da sind alle Versionen des Films, die mal irgendwie im Kino gelaufen sind drin. Also die erste, die eigentliche und die andere. Und dann ganz großartig gibt es eine Soundspur. Kann ich jedem nur empfehlen. Also wer Brasil mag, das ist wirklich die Ausgabe, die man mal sehen will. Da gibt es einfach eine Tonspur, wo Terry Gilliam während der Film läuft, zu jeder Szene Kommentare macht. Ist jetzt auch nicht so besonders. Da gibt es viele Varianten für viele Filme. Aber hat mich natürlich bei Brasil besonders umgehauen, weil ich nämlich diesen Film, ohne Witz im Kino, glaube ich, 15 Mal gesehen habe. Und ich habe ihn 15 Mal im Kino gesehen und ich habe ihn nicht ein einziges Mal auf Video gesehen. Bis dahin. Und ich dachte wirklich, ich kenne jedes Detail von diesem Film. Eins kann sich dann doch nicht, ja. Eine Sache ist mir entgangen. Aber ansonsten, naja.
So, wo du jetzt gerade so schön ruhig bist, die haben in der kleinen Kiste rumstehen, so eine schwarze.
MacWorld machen wir einen Strich drunter jetzt.
MacWorld können wir einen Strich drunter machen, oder? Wir haben sogar über iTunes jetzt lange gesprochen. Ach, wie fandet ihr Philnote?
Wen?
Er war nervös. Ich glaube, er war nervös.
Also ich fand auch, dass Steve das durchaus ein bisschen Souveräner gemacht hat.
Er war nervös. Aber er hatte auch einen Auftrag. Also er war glaube ich offiziell bewaffnet worden. Das hat man schon beim ersten Kommentar gemerkt, über wie viele Kunden sie haben. Was haben sie gesagt? Sie meinten erst mal, wir haben 6 Billionen Songs, irgendwie bei iTunes.
Und 75 Millionen Kreditkarten.
Da spricht man ja auch was ganz anderes. Das red ich gar nicht von iTunes. Verdammte Scheiße. Ich rede von... Wovon rede ich denn eigentlich? Wie viele Macintosh-Benutzer sie haben? Na sie meinten doch dann irgendwie, ja... Ah ja, genau, die Retail-Stores. Entschuldigung. Also genau, die Retail-Stores hier hab ich's. 3,4 Millionen Kunden pro Woche laufen durch Retail-Stores.
Das sind hundertmal so viele wie bei der MacWorld.
Genau, hundert MacWorlds pro Woche.
Pro Woche, das ist natürlich...
Das heißt, wir haben 52 Mal pro Jahr jeweils hundert MacWorlds laufen. Und ich meine, warum sollte er ausgerechnet auf der MacWorld so einen Spruch sagen?
Warum wohl? Weil sie zurückwollen, auswollen.
Ja, einfach jedem dann auch nochmal final klarzumachen, warum sie einfach so diese scheiß Veranstaltungen nicht mehr haben wollen. Weil es ihnen auch vom Timing her einfach nicht passt. Das ist sinnvoll.
Man muss auch wirklich sagen, ich meine, diese hundert MacWorlds pro Woche, die kosten sie kein Geld, mit denen verdienen sie noch Geld. Also für die MacWorld muss man ja theoretisch noch bezahlen, damit sie dabei sind und Vorbereitung und was auch immer.
Total teuer.
Und Messestand, das kostet ja richtig Schweine Geld. Und mit den Stores verdienen sie richtig Anstand.
Ja, und ich muss auch sagen, was mich in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen angeödet hat, das ist auch, was jetzt dieses Mal wieder war, also diese Erwartung, Erwartung, Erwartung, Erwartung, die Keynote und dann so, das war aber eine scheiß Keynote, weil es wurde ja das und das und das nicht vorgestellt. Und das wird jetzt einfach wegfallen. Jetzt wird es einfach mal eine Woche vorher kommt irgendwie ein Special Event und dann alle so, es gibt wieder was Neues, toll. Und es ist egal, was es ist.
Aber die CES werden sie immer noch mal killen wollen, oder? Komm.
Die CES killt sich schon von alleine. Also solche Trade-Shows sind einfach mal Dinosaurier, die sind bald tot.
Menschenskinder fällt mir auf, ist ja dieses Jahr dann auch die erste ohne Bill? Ohne Bill Gates, die erste CES? Oder hat der letztes Jahr, vorletztes Jahr schon seine letzte gehabt?
Hat der bisher auf jeder CES eine Rede gehalten?
Der hat seit Jahren auf jeder CES eine Keynote gehalten. Und hat jetzt letztes oder vorletztes...
Vielleicht war das nur aus Solidarität.
Aus Mitleid.
Sagen wir Solidarität.
Das weiß doch bestimmt der Chat, oder?
Wenn Bill keine Keynote hält, dann halte ich auch keine. Naja, aber sich mit Bill Gates zu messen, ist jetzt eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt sein Ding, oder? Es wird schon wieder abwegig. Wir können noch mal kurz hier in die Kommentare schauen, denn wir sollten auch immer, immer an die Hörer denken. In unserem Blog ein Frag zu dieser Sendung, wo noch Fragen sind, die sich jetzt auf die MacWorld beziehen.
Ich fand ganz hübsch, dass er diesen anderen Typen, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß, iMovie hat vorstellen lassen, weil das fand ich so richtig schön begeistert, wie der sein iMovie vorgestellt hat. Ein bisschen sehr begeistert, aber das war echt eine schöne Demo. Das hätte Phil definitiv nicht so schön hingekriegt.
Ja, der hätte es wahrscheinlich nicht ordentlich bedienen können.
Und wie der wirklich so diesen Schnitt da hingekriegt hat, dieses ins Wasser reinspringen, da habe ich mir gedacht, wow, ich will auch mal wieder iMovie machen, auch wenn ich nie zwei Aufnahmen aus zwei Kameraperspektiven haben werde.
So, ich gehe mal hier kurz durch die Kommentare durch, was sich jetzt auf die MacWorld bezieht, weil wenn wir das jetzt abschließen wollen, dann sollten wir das vielleicht jetzt mal auch machen. Wann denkt ihr, kommt ein iMac-Update? Wird gefragt. Gute Frage. Wenn du mich fragst, innerhalb der nächsten vier Wochen.
Das ist jetzt wirklich so richtig schön. Hoffentlich bald.
Ja, also sehr lange wird es nicht dauern. Ich rechne mit so einem Special Event vielleicht noch.
Dieses Jahr.
Bleibt das Gehäuse so klein oder wird es ein größeres Gehäuse werden?
iMac ist alles dasselbe.
Da kommt irgendwie Display-Port rein, da kommt irgendwie auf eine 3,5 Zoll-Festplatte rein, damit man richtig schön Gas geben kann.
Schon ein LED Bildschirm, hat noch LCD, oder? Dann wechseln sie da vielleicht auch.
Das weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Der iMac? Ich glaube, der hat eine normale Hintergrundbeleuchtung. Das waren bisher nur die 15 Zoll MacBooks.
Müssen wir da auch wechseln.
Wow, stehst du zufälligerweise vor einem Wasserfall? Wer? Nein.
Ne, hier rauscht gerade was. Das wird kein Mensch. Ja, so, dann kommt gleich die nächste Frage. Wann kommt der neue Mac Mini? Ich würde sagen...
Ach, wir waren jetzt gerade beim iMac, nicht beim Mac.
Ja, wir waren beim iMac. Und ich würde sagen, der Mac Mini kommt auf derselben Veranstaltung raus.
So nebenbei. Also wie gesagt, für den hoffe ich auf eine 3.2.Fest-Party.
Vielleicht ist das auch eine Veranstaltung, wo sie den neuen Mac Pro, wie auch immer sein mag, vorstellen.
Und den Popline ist mir noch was aus der Tasche gefallen.
Ja, und dann haben sie alles einfach auf dieses komische Display-Port umgestellt. Was ich ja sehr schön finde, ist dieses Gerücht, dass der Mac Mini einen Mini DVI-Stecker beibehalten können, soll, haben, sollte, wisst ihr.
Aber ich glaube, auf solche Gerüchte braucht man nicht allzu viel zu geben, oder?
Warum?
Weil, Gerüchte.
Das finde ich ganz, also, erstens ist es so, dass der Display-Port ja theoretisch auch zwei Bildschirme treiben könnte. Denn das kann ja Display-Port bei Design, bei Speck. Ob das dann auch in dem Ding wirklich geht und so weiter, und wie teuer der Adapter ist, um so weiter das auch wirklich zu machen, ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Würden Sie jetzt noch einen Mac Mini, oh Mann, einen Mini DVI-Port noch zusätzlich mit drin haben?
Könnte man da theoretisch drei Bildschirme anschließen? Oder was willst du sagen?
Ja, aber vor allem der Mini DVI-Port hat halt auch ein Video-Signal noch. Da ist Video und S-Video noch mit drauf. Was ja bei dem Display-Port nicht mehr der Fall ist.
Mit einem Wort, man kriegt das auch noch an ältere Fernseher ran?
Genau, man kriegt das auch noch an ältere Fernseher ran, man kriegt das an Beamer ran. Der Mac Mini wird, glaube ich, von vielen Leuten in so einer Media-Präsentation- Umgebung angeschlossen. Da würden sie das Produkt komplett wegkillen. Das wäre eine interessante Variante. Ich fände das cool. Ich denke, das Dual-Hat ist eins der meist nachgefragten Features. Ich kenne fast niemanden, der einen Mac Mini hat, der nicht als erstes sagen würde, ich möchte zwei Bildschirme anschließen. Das wäre die Lösung, weil dann habe ich meinen Fernseher und meinen Computerbildschirm dran. Dann habe ich einen Rechner, den ich als Terminal benutzen kann, mit einem ordentlichen Screen, wo ich davor sitzen kann. Aber ich kann auch meine Filme abspielen auf The Big Screen und mich aufs Sofa legen und mir das anschauen.
Ich habe keinen Mac Mini, noch keinen, aber ich würde das nicht machen wollen. Ich würde das ausschließlich an Fernseher anschließen wollen.
Denis, hast du einen Mac Mini?
Okay, und wir wissen auch nicht so genau, wann er kommt.
Ich habe noch meinen Laptop an so einem schicken Cinema Display und dann habe ich hier noch nebenan einen G4 Dual 500 MHz stehen. Aber der ist eigentlich dauerhaft seit ewig schon. Zu langsam.
Ja, so, dann ist ein iPhone Nano noch realistisch. Ich glaube, das war noch nie realistisch.
Ich glaube, das ist realistisch.
Was?
Ich glaube, das hat ein Gewinn.
Ihr solltet wieder wetten.
Won't happen. Won't happen.
Willst du deine Kiste Marte zurückgewinnen?
Ja, findet nicht statt. Also nicht dieses Jahr. Nee, nee, das werden sie nicht machen. Das ist Quatsch. Dann heißt hier, schreibt iPhoto jetzt IPTC-Tags.
Was für ein Zeug?
Na, das sind IPTC-Tags. Jetzt komme ich gerade selber ins... Wir reden jetzt International Press Telecommunications Council. Das wissen wir nicht.
Egal was es ist, wissen wir nicht.
Doch, wissen wir, weil da steht in den Kommentaren ungefähr zwei Kommentare später. Ja, weil iPhoto schon in iLife 08 IPTC-Tags schreibt. Was sind IPTC-Tags?
Das sind Metadaten für sowas. Und das sind so alle möglichen Sachen. Und ich kann ja jetzt nicht genau sagen, wofür das verwendet wird.
Photometer-Data-Standard.
Keine Ahnung. Das frag ich ja. Kann ich sozusagen mit Antworten, genau. Angeblich macht das aber iLife 08 schon. Lesen, lesen. Siehst du auch so ein bisschen? Ihr fragt einer, ob Picasso sei schnell hässlich, sei es auch evil? Fragezeichen müssen wir nicht beantworten, oder? Nein. Benutzt ihr momentan iPhoto bzw. iWorks? Ja. Werdet ihr sofort auf 09 wechseln?
Ja.
Werdet ihr ein zukünftiges Mac-Box-Set kaufen? Nein, weil ihr schon iWorks gekauft habt. Aber es ist ein gutes Angebot, finde ich. Also es ist echt billig.
Was kostet es in Deutschland?
Weiß ich nicht, aber was haben sie gesagt? 169 Dollar. 169 Dollar. Das wird wahrscheinlich ähnlich hier landen.
Und das Coole ist, für alle Leute, die immer noch irgendwie 10,4 haben, die kriegen auch gleich einen Leopard mit dazu. Also Jungs.
Ja, und das kann ich nochmal sagen. Vor Weihnachten ist meiner Tante die Festplatte abgestorben. Jetzt direkt nach Weihnachten hat mich jetzt ein Freund angehauen, dass ihm die Festplatte gestorben ist. Und das war überall ein lautes Rumgeschrei, weil natürlich alle keine Backups gemacht haben. Geht in euren nächsten Blablabla-Markt, holt euch irgendwie eine Terabyte-Platte für einen Hunderter, holt euch Leopard.
90 Euro.
Und macht Updates, äh, Backups.
Ne, 85 Euro sogar nur.
Oder 85. Also ich hab mir eine Terabyte-Platte für einen Hunderter geholt. Jetzt gerade mal wieder. Passend zu der großen neuen 500 GB Festplatte war meine Backup-Platte plötzlich kleiner als meine.
Zu dem Drobo-Thema kommen wir ja noch, weil dann kann ich auch ein bisschen was erzählen.
So, dann wird hier noch behauptet, Apple wartet wohl auf die neue Intel i7-Serie. Das mag sein. Ich hab mich damit nicht so sehr beschäftigt, aber da steht mal wieder so eine neue Prozessor-Generation an. Mit mehr Chores und so.
Ist i7, ist das nicht diese ganz kleine? Diese Netbook-artigen noch mal irgendwie in dem Dreh? Nee, ne.
Die Fetten, die irgendwie ordentlich Wurm haben. Genau.
Wenn du wieder hypers oder den kommt jetzt wieder und so.
Was wir von der Geo-Tagging-Verbindung mit Flickr halten, ob das ein Datensicherheitsrisiko ist? Naja, also ich meine generell, wenn man am Internet teilnimmt und wenn man GPS-Devices, die das in Dateiformaten speichern, teilnimmt, dann ist das sicherlich unter Umständen auch ein Datensicherheitsrisiko. Das muss eben jetzt jeder selber machen. Und natürlich erzeugt das auch Bewegungsprofile. Ich würde jetzt aber nicht sagen, dass jetzt bei iPhoto oder iLive generell da jetzt mehr bestehen als mit allen anderen Tools.
Naja, ich sehe es ein bisschen in der Beziehung, dass man, also was mir aufgefallen ist, wenn man zum Beispiel mit dem iPhone ein Foto macht und dann verschickt man das per Mail, zum Beispiel an den beliebten Dienst Twitterpick, den ich gerne mal nutze. Also das ist so ein Dienst, womit man bei Twitter Bilder aufladen kann. Dann ist da auch meine aktuelle Position drin. Und wenn ich bloß mal glaube, von meiner Katze im Hinterhofen ein Foto zu machen, dann wissen die Leute dann schon relativ genau, wo ich wohne. Das ist nichts, was man nicht auch im Telefonbuch nachschlagen könnte. Aber dass man in Zukunft gerne mal, also dass die Befahre besteht, dass man mehr verschickt, als man auf den ersten Blick glaubt, ist relativ hoch beziehungsweise.
Aber du weißt es ja, weil dein Telefon fragt dich ja dreimal, ob du wirklich das mit dem Location anhabst.
Ja, aber ich denk doch nicht dran, dass wenn ich da eine Mail jetzt rumschicke, dass da immer noch diese Daten drin sind.
Also die Leute, die dir da nicht dran denken, denen ist sowieso egal, was mit ihrer Location passiert.
Nee, ist es nicht. Das ist ein Problem. Entweder sollte man diese Daten rausfiltern oder man sollte fragen oder man sollte sonst was machen. Ja, also ich finde, es ist ein Datenschutzproblem.
Aber ein lösbares.
Keins, was wir jetzt noch weiter diskutieren müssen. Ist die enttäuschende Keynote, da haben wir es wieder, eine Konsequenz des Ausstiegs von Apple aus der MacWorld. Ich finde, die Enttäuschung ist sozusagen das Problem, dass eben die Leute Erwartungshaltung haben, die sie dann enttäuschen.
Ein schönes neues iLife, ein ganz neues Macbook, was wollt ihr mehr?
Ich finde es auch völlig in Ordnung.
Achso, natürlich iTunes.
Gibt es eigentlich ein neues iTunes, weil es gibt irgendwie kein neues iTunes, oder? Nö.
Ne, es gibt kein neues iTunes, das sind alles Erinnerungen im Store sozusagen. Hier fragt einer, ob ich mal was zu meiner Telefonanlage sage.
Mein CD-Stapel hat sich gerade verabschiedet und ist irgendwie vom Tisch gefallen. Und Scheiß.
Dann fragt einer, ob ich nicht mal was zum Thema Telefonanlage sagen, bloggen wollte. Twitter, ach so, ja, er sucht auch gerade eine. Ach ja, weiß nie, ob das jetzt wirklich hierher gehört, muss ich sagen.
Ja, dann machst du eine Chaos-Radio-Extrasendung von...
Ach, ja, ich suche die 8-Stunden-Sendung.
Ja, aber ich bin wirklich sehr unglücklich mit meiner Telefonanlage. Ich weiß nicht, wenn wir am Ende noch Zeit haben, dann kann ich ja gerne mal was zu meiner Telefonanlage sagen.
Aber wir haben noch ein paar Themen hier auf dem...
Es kommt ja noch das Mega-Drobo-Thema.
Es kommt noch Mega-Drobo. Wir sind auch ganz nah dran. Ich scroll jetzt hier mal schnell durch. La, la, la. 8 GB RAM hast du noch gesagt. Das ist ein 9-17 Zoll-Macbook. Das ist wohl recht teuer. Offizieller Aufpreis 1080 Euro.
Ja, die spenden ja natürlich total. Aber ich meine, das ist ja auch total egal, weil sie schreiben offiziell, dass es reingeht, reinpasst und dann kann man sich das auch woanders kaufen, wenn es den entsprechenden passenden Speicher gibt. Und natürlich will man mehr als 4 Gig haben. 4 Gig war irgendwie seit zwei Jahren angesagt. Jetzt will man irgendwie 8 haben.
Ja, aber ich bin mal sehr gespannt, was so die ersten 4 Gigabyte-Riegel kosten, die es so draußen gibt. Was kosten die so? Die sind auch nicht gerade billig. Also klar, es ist ein absolut hoher Aufpreis.
Dann wird ihr noch behauptet, ich würde ploppen. Das ist ja wohl eine Frechheit. Und Gitar-Lessons mit Farin Urlaub wären toll. Das stimmt. Ja, das ist doch mal ein kreativer Kommentar. Super, vielen Dank auch immer für euer Feedback. An dieser Stelle kann man auch gleich nochmal sagen, könnt ihr gerne hinterlassen, auch in den Kommentaren zu dieser Sendung, wenn wir sie dann veröffentlicht haben als Podcast. Denn wir lesen das immer mit großer Begeisterung.
Und wie schaltet die Kommentare auch? Oder Tim auch? Wir schalten die Kommentare mal frei.
Wir schalten sie fleißig frei. Und auch wenn ihr schreibt, mal sehen, ob ihr den freischaltet, den schalten wir dann auch frei. Da haben wir irgendwie überhaupt keine Schmerzen. So, noch ein kurzer Nachtrag zur letzten Sendung. Also MacWorld ist jetzt geschlossen. Ein kurzer Nachtrag zur letzten Sendung. Ich hatte mich beschwert, dass Cut und Paste eine Pein ist, weil wenn man styled Text kopiert, ihn dann an bestimmten Stellen styled kriegt, wo man ihn einfach nicht styled haben will. Ja, dann wurde ich von vielen Seiten darauf hingewiesen, ganz zurecht, dass es offensichtlich tatsächlich als Standard-Menü-Item in allen Programmen, die quasi styled Text haben, nicht nur Paste mit Apple-V gibt, sondern auch Paste with Current Style.
Was im Deutschen etwas dämlich heißt? All-Shift-Apple-V einsetzen und Stil anpassen.
Paste and Match-Style meinste?
Current Style, Match-Style, weiß ich nicht. Ich hab jetzt bei Omni-Outliner gerade geguckt, ich schau mal bei Text-Edit, richtig Paste und Match.
Control, All-Shift-Command drücken.
All-Shift, Apple-V. Es ist furchtbar. Genau, und ich hätte eigentlich lieber Apple-V, sollte so wie dieses alle Badewannentasten drücken, V funktionieren und dann irgendwie einen Paste mit übernehmen, alle Styles, weil ich will fast nie übernehmen. So, da hab ich mir so ein bisschen vor den Kopf gehauen, weil ich muss sagen, das ist mir entgangen. Und ich weiß noch nicht mal seit wann es das gibt.
Wahrscheinlich seit 10.
Meinst du nicht, dass es das seit 10.0 gibt?
Vermutlich.
Das wäre schon sehr...
Ja, weil man natürlich als Profi für Cut & Paste nicht ins Menü guckt, ist doch klar. Bist dann nie gewesen.
Also hier Copy & Paste Profis.
Ich fand das schon ein bisschen peinlich. Ich war peinlich berührt. Allerdings muss ich dazu noch einschränkend sagen, es löst nicht alle Probleme. Also ich hab immer so Fälle, es gibt Programme, die halten sich da einfach nicht an die richtigen Standards. Zum Beispiel Eyecare ist so ein Ding, wo ich da irgendwas in die Location reinpaste und so und da gibt's dann halt dieses Menü auch nicht. Und deswegen will ich da auch nicht vorher Weihnachten... Nee, der kommt dann irgendwie nicht klar mit Style Text und pastet dann auch nicht und ist irgendwie alles so ein bisschen elend. Wollte ich noch mal gesagt haben, falls jemand dieses Problem hat, dass er immer Style Text kopiert und er will es eigentlich nicht...
Also hier meint jemand, dass es das schon auf Next gegeben hätte.
Ah, wirklich? Ach, interessant. Okay, dann ist das... Dann war es definitiv bei 10.0 schon dabei. Fein. Ja. So, womit wollen wir weitermachen? Drobo? Ich habe mir ein Drobo gekauft.
Tim hat sich ein Drobo gekauft, wie jeder mitbekommen hat, der bei Twitter... Man braucht ja gar nicht zu followen.
Ich habe mich vom Bits und so Adventskalender überreden lassen. Ich hatte schon immer erwogen, sowas zu haben. Und vor allem wollte ich so ein Secondary Storage haben, neben meiner Time Capsule, um einen Backup von meinem Backup machen zu können. Und generell hätte ich ja natürlich auch ganz gerne mal was, wo man so seine ausgelagerten Daten draufwerfen kann, weil man muss ja nur wirklich...
Was ist überhaupt ein DROBO, Tim?
DROBO steht für Data Robotics und ist ein RAID-System mit eigener Intelligenz. Sprich, das ist so eine kleine rechtwinklige Schüssel, wo man bis zu 4 3,5 Zoll Festplatten, SATA oder SATA 2, reinstecken kann. Und das eben auch alles on the fly und während das Ding in Betrieb ist. Und er macht halt aus diesen 2, 3 oder 4 Festplatten, die man da reinsteckt, also 2 müssen da mindestens drin sein. Ja, bietet der dir ja so ein Volume an und du kannst halt zur Laufzeit Platten rausnehmen, wenn sie kaputt sind oder wenn du sie halt vergrößern möchtest.
Das ist nämlich das, bei so normalen Ratesystemen kann man ja immer nur Festplatten der selben Größe wieder reinpacken. Da müssen die Festplatten, wenn eine Festplatte kaputt ist.
Oder größer, aber das nützt dir auch nichts, weil dann wird der Rest sozusagen ignoriert.
Das weiß ich nicht so genau.
Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher, weil ich hab in diesem Drobolator, also dem Kalkulator, wo man seine Größen so berechnen kann, so mit Festplatten, wie man denkt, wie man die so hat, kann man sich verschiedene Festplatten so per Web-Interface da so reinziehen. Und die sagen zwar, man kann verschiedene Größen nehmen, aber ob jetzt auch die Größe dann komplett ausgenutzt wird, war ich mir irgendwie noch nicht so sicher. Ich glaube, sie sagen, es geht, aber die lassen dann auch bestimmte Bereiche ungenutzt. So kam es mir vor, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Der Effekt, den du wahrscheinlich gehabt hast, ist, dass du so viermal die gleiche Größe drin hattest und dann eine größer gemacht hast und es hat sich nichts geändert.
Genau.
Du brauchst mindestens zwei Platten von der größten Kapazität, bevor das durchschlägt.
Ja, weil er dann wieder das in Möhre aufteilt und den einen größer macht und den anderen kleiner. Also ich glaube, das ist das gleiche Problem wie bei Raids auch, nur dass die es halt intelligent lösen und anders bewerben. Der Platz bleibt einfach ungenutzt.
Ja, soweit ist das Ding irgendwie auch alles ganz gut. Ich habe mir dieses Teil hier hingestellt und habe vier Mal einen Gigabyte Platten da rein getan. Natürlich, Terabyte. Oh Gott, ich lege schon wieder in der Vergangenheit. Und naja, dann habe ich da so ein Volume drauf gemacht und da wird man dann erstmal gefragt, wie groß soll denn jetzt bitte dieses Volume sein? Und angeboten wird einem zwei Gigabyte, vier Gigabyte, acht Gigabyte und 16 Gigabyte.
Tera oder Giga?
Das 21. Jahrhundert, das macht mich wahnsinnig.
Was ist dann das nächste eigentlich nach Tera?
Das war aber jetzt, ja. Und dann kommt Peter.
Okay, kannst du dich schon mal dran gewöhnen.
Kommt bald. Ich weiß es gerade nicht. Ist auf jeden Fall alles viel zu groß. Jetzt haben wir erst mal Terra. Dann hab ich diese vier Platten da reingesteckt und dann fangen die so an zu laufen. Dann blinkt der da fleißig dran rum und dann installiert man einen Treiber bzw. so eine Management-Software. Das Drobo-Dashboard. Das kam mir schon so ein bisschen halb sein vor, weil das ist halt so ein Weiß-Installer. Weißt du, dieser uralt MacOS-Installer, der immer alles ein bisschen anders macht.
Wo man schon diese Ahnung hat, dass da irgendjemand sich dran gesetzt hat, der noch nie für Mac Pro gewartet hat.
Wo man dem auch einfach schon so ein bisschen, ich weiß auch nicht, ich weiß nicht, was die Leute an diesem Weiß so toll finden. Das mag ja ein paar komische Features haben, aber irgendwie, mir stimmte das schon mal nicht besonders vertrauenswert.
Mit diesem Weiß-Installer meint jetzt nicht Weiß, die Farbe man jetzt. Ich will ja ganz woanders, sondern dieses V-I-S-E.
Das ist schon so ein Standard-Installer, den man sich für Geld dazukaufen kann. Für Leute, die den von Apple mitgelieferten Installer aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht nehmen wollen.
Genau.
Und der sieht immer sehr, sehr nach Carbon aus. Also da blendet einem immer erst mal irgendwas entgegen, was man so nicht haben möchte.
Naja, das Ding installiert ja auf jeden Fall ein Programm, das Drobo-Dashboard.
Installiert das mehr als dieses Programm? Also installiert das nur echte Treiber oder nur dieses Programm?
Das ist zum Beispiel so eine Sache, die man halt bei so einem Weiß-Installer eben nicht weiß. Nicht Weiß. Weil, während man beim normalen Standard-Mac OS X-Installer immer schön Apple-E machen kann, und dann kriegst du die komplette Liste der zu installierenden Dateien. Du weißt zwar nicht genau, wo sie hingehen, aber so relativ, und dann weißt du schon in etwa, was da so kommt.
Wenn KX dransteht, weiß man, was Sache ist.
Ja, also das ist in der Regel relativ zu rot, oder es ist halt nur eine Applikation, das ist halt relativ zur Applications. Also ging auch noch schöner, aber zumindest hat man da diesen Einblick. Wer das auch jetzt nicht kennt, also wenn man so Standard-Installer macht, geht man da ins Menü, kann man sich irgendwie angucken lassen. Zumindest wenn man den ersten oder zweiten Schritt übersprungen hat.
Genau, das geht nämlich erst in dem Schritt, an dem man die Festplatte auswählt, auf die man es installiert. Warum auch immer.
Ich glaube, das war am Anfang so, und mittlerweile ist es wieder anders. Ich weiß es jetzt nicht. Aber es geht auf jeden Fall, bevor man irgendwas Böses tut.
Man kann sich die Liste auch sichern, falls man es wieder deinstallieren will. Das ist schon ganz schick.
Ja, dann kommt dieses Drobo-Dashboard hoch, so ein kleines Programm, es kommt mit so einem kleinen Fenster hoch, da ist dann nur dieses Drobo-Icon drin und irgendwie so ein Help-Button. Wenn man auf diesen Help-Button klickt, dann kommt so ein komischer Help, so eine HTML-Help hoch, mit so merkwürdigen Windows 3.11-artigen Buttons, die einem das Gefühl geben, dass das Ganze, diese ganze Hilfe mal aus einer Windows, HTML-basierten Windows-Hilfe generiert worden ist.
Da fühlt es sich aus, als ob es direkt aus einer CHM-Datei stammen würde, oder?
Es ist irgendwie, ich hab schon mal hübschere Sachen gesehen.
Was ist das da für ein Kasten, bei dem da unten drunter steht?
Das ist der Drobo-Share, da sag ich gleich noch was dazu, den hab ich aber nicht. Wie auch immer. Wenn man jetzt dieses Drobo anschließt, also wenn das Ding direkt mit USB angeschlossen ist, dann kann man den eben auch verwalten. Man kann ihn aber auch nur dann verwalten, wenn er direkt über USB angeschlossen ist. Also nicht irgendwie übers Netz oder so, weil er hat ja kein Netz.
Und auch nicht über Firewire?
Du könntest das sicherlich auch über Firewire machen.
Du hast jetzt einen alten oder einen neuen?
Ich habe den neuen, Second Generation, der hat Firewire 800.
Und so hast du ihn auch angeschlossen?
Und zwei Stück, nee, habe ich nicht, weil ich habe ja keinen Firewire 800, ich habe Firewire 400 und ich habe so einen Adapterkabel nicht. Also habe ich den über USB angeschlossen. Und ich wollte ihn ja letzten Endes sowieso über USB betreiben an der Time Capsule. Na ja, so dann stand ich da und durfte jetzt erstmal ein Volume machen und wusste nicht so recht, was damit anzufangen, dass ich jetzt so eine Volume-Größe machen muss. Aber da wurde mir sozusagen das erste Mal nochmal so klar, das ist etwas, worüber ich völlig darüber nachgedacht habe. Ja, ich mache da ein HFS-Volume drauf. Und HFS, wie so viele andere Dateisysteme auch, kennen nicht das Prinzip, dass eine Festplatte sich unter ihrem Arsch die Größe ändert. Sondern das ist eigentlich etwas, was halt zum Zeitpunkt der Erstellung eines Dateisystems mehr oder weniger klar definiert ist. Das ändert sich dann halt nicht. Und die ganze Layout-Struktur, die Direktur, die Blockgrößen usw. richtet sich danach. Jetzt bietet dir aber der Drobo die Möglichkeit, ein Volume anzulegen, was dem Rechner gegenüber sagt, ich bin sehr groß, auch wenn diese Speicherkapazität eigentlich gar nicht vorliegt. Sodass du nachträglich größere, also über die Zeit, dann Platten nachschieben kannst und ohne, dass du eben irgendwas nochmal runter und wieder komplett drauf kopieren musst, wächst dann eben auch der real zur Verfügung stehende Speicherplatz. Das ist an sich eine pfiffige Sache, weil darum geht es ja hier auch. Jetzt habe ich viermal einen Terabyte drin, mit RAID bleiben da netto 2,7 Terabyte über.
Und was zeigt dir dein Rechner an, wenn du es ansteckst?
Er sagt dann, wenn ich da ein 8TB-Volumen drauf formatiert habe, dann sagt er, hier sind 8TB.
Achso, also du legst...
Da sind auch so und so viele Terabyte frei.
Du kannst sagen, wie viel du da gerne anlegen würdest.
Genau, aber dann ist das sozusagen auch inherent auf diesem Platten-System gespeichert und der Rechner glaubt fortan, dass diese 8TB eben auch tatsächlich zur Verfügung stehen. Auch wenn sie das tatsächlich nicht tun. Das Gerät hat nur zwei Konzepte.
Da stellt sich natürlich mal eine spannende Frage.
Die beantworte ich gleich.
Das ist doch voll schummel.
Naja, aber das Ding ist, das Problem können sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht anders lösen.
Weil das Fallsystem scheiße ist.
Weil das Fallsystem scheiße ist. Und das ist halt jetzt ihr Ansatz. Und das ist insofern auch kein Problem, wenn du so ein Ding benutzt, in dem du einfach da deine Daten drauflegst. Und dann liegen die da drauf. Wenn du deine großen Projekte, was weiß ich, du nimmst Audio, Video auf und hast immer diese diese zehn Gigabyte großen Ordner, die du halt nicht gleich wegschmeißen willst, weil könnte man ja nochmal gebrauchen, aber die du jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit auf deiner Laptop-Festplatte rumschleppen möchtest, weil so viele 10 Gigabyte Chunks hast du halt nicht. Also Drag City einfach auf deine Platte, auf dein Drobo drauf und weg ist es.
Aber hat nicht Time Machine damit ein ganz massives Problem?
Genau.
Wir machen den jetzt fertig jetzt.
Ja, genau, da komme ich gleich zu. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu dem Drobo. Der hat unten so eine blaue Lichtleiste von zehn blauen LEDs und die zeigen dir an, wie viel Platz von dem logisch wirklich vorhandenen Platz da ist. Also die Netto-Speichermenge. In diesem Fall bei mir eben die 2,7 Terabyte. Wie viel davon belegt sind, das zeigt er mir halt so an. Und das sehe ich sozusagen, indem ich nur aufs angeschlossene Gerät schaue. Das ist ganz cool. Das heißt, man blickt da einfach drauf, man sieht, aha, fünf Lampen an. Das Ding ist halb voll. Aber wenn du da sozusagen jetzt nur mit einem Computer, der nicht dieses Drobo-Dashboard installiert hat, draufschaust, dann hast du keine Ahnung, wie das da wirklich aussieht. Das Drobo-Dashboard schlüsselt dir das dann eben genau auf. Wie viel ist netto da? Wie viel ist wirklich belegt? Wie viel ist Spare für Recovery?
Weißt du, was mich gleich patentieren lasse? Die Idee, wie sie das lösen können.
Na, die Lösung heißt ZFS.
Ja, aber für die Übergangsphase.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es lösen können. Auf jeden Fall.
Die Übergangsphase heißt die Lösung. Unsichtbare Datei, die vorgibt, genauso groß zu sein und an den Stellen liegt.
Okay, ich erklär's dir gleich. Also, wenn du schon richtig gesagt hast, Time Machine ist ein Problem, weil Time Machine arbeitet auf der Basis, ich schreibe hier so lange Backups, bis sie voll sind, und dann fange ich an zu löschen. Wenn du also jetzt so ein 8TB Volumes einrichtest, wo nur 2,7 frei sind, schreib das Ding einfach munter auf diese Platte drauf los, obwohl es gar nicht mehr geht. Der Drobo reagiert dann ganz komisch. Das habe ich jetzt nicht ausgetestet, weil ich das Ding so voll nicht gemacht habe. Das konnte ich auch gar nicht. Das werde ich auch gleich noch erzählen. Er slowt dann irgendwie alles runter. Er macht die Zugriffe langsam. Was das jetzt soll, weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich denken sie sich, du schaust sowieso die ganze Zeit auf die blauen Lampen. Und wenn die alle an sind, dann musst du halt tätig werden. Und wenn jetzt wirklich einer massiv schreibt, dann mache ich ihn einfach ganz langsam, damit es nicht so voll geschrieben wird. Aber irgendwann muss er ja auch...
Damit man es mitkriegt, dass er so...
Keine Ahnung, irgendwann muss er ja auch irgendwelche sinnvollen Fehlermeldungen ausspucken. Also irgendwann kann er das eben auch einfach nicht mehr speichern.
Aber so schlau ist er nicht, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall muss man auch vorsichtig sein.
Aber auf deren Webseite steht, dass Time Machine zu 100% kompatibel ist mit dem Drobo.
Das ist eigentlich eine Lüge. Das ist eigentlich eine Lüge. Die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich jetzt auf einer Webseite gefunden habe, ein pfiffiger Vorschlag, wie man das umgehen kann, ist, dass man sein Backup in ein Disc-Image macht, was auf diesem Drobo liegt und diesem Disc-Image wiederum sagt man, du bist nur so groß, wie eben tatsächlich physikalisch Platz da ist. Bloß damit dreht sich das Ganze wieder im Kreis. In dem Moment, wo du dann halt größere Platten reintust und wirklich mehr Platz hast, müsstest du dieses ganze Disc-Image wegschmeißen und durch ein größeres ersetzen.
Aber du hast doch schon alle vier Platten reingepackt. Du kannst doch eigentlich die richtige Größe nehmen, weil es doch schon maximal groß ist. Oder muss man das machen, falls man das Ding irgendwann mal wachsen lassen will, wenn du dir dann im halben Jahr 1,5...
Also erstens ist die richtige Größe ja nicht 2,4, 8 oder 16, sondern 2,7. Und zweitens kann ich ja hier jederzeit zwei Platten rausnehmen und durch 1,5 Terabyte Platten ersetzen und dann habe ich eben schon wieder mehr Platz. Und das geht dann aber auch locker irgendwie über die vier hinaus, wenn nicht glaube ich 4 mal 1,5. Nein, da noch nicht, aber wie auch immer. Zwei Terabyte Platten stehen quasi vor der Tür, das wird jetzt nicht lange dauern, dann gibt es die und dann sind die da drin und so weiter. Also es ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was man bedenken muss. Ich sage jetzt nicht, der Drobo ist nicht eine Option für Leute, weil an sich ist ja dieses Handling ganz cool, dass eben dieses ganze Management des Rates im Gerät ist. Das ist an sich eine gute Idee.
Aber dieses Versprechen sozusagen, hey, du hast da ein Ratesystem drin, mach dir aber nie Gedanken drum, das scheinen sie offensichtlich nicht zu erfüllen zu können.
Tja, jetzt wird's auf jeden Fall, jetzt wird's ein bisschen eklig. Ich hab also jetzt da ein paar Daten drauf geschmissen, so in der Größenordnung von ungefähr einem Terabyte. Hab einfach drauf kopiert. Und das ging auch relativ fix. Hat irgendwie so mit 25 Megabyte pro Sekunde geschrieben über USB. Hat auch genauso schnell von der Firewire-Platte gelesen. Ich weiß nicht, ob er noch schneller schreiben könnte. Auf jeden Fall hat er das nicht.
Richtig, mehr geht über USB nicht, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher.
Ich glaube, das ist relativ endlich.
Kann sein. Ist auf jeden Fall schon irgendwie erstmal so ein ganz, ganz brauchbarer Speed. Also bei solchen Weckarchivierungssachen, da kommst du halt nun wirklich jetzt nicht auf die Sekunde an, auch wenn schneller immer besser ist. Dann, nach einem Tag, leuchtete die eine Platte rot.
Das ging aber schnell.
Ja, das dachte ich mir auch. Das ging aber schnell. Da war sozusagen eine von meinen vier frisch gekauften Platten wurde von dem Drobo als kaputt ausgewiesen. Und ich dachte mir so, oha, da ist wohl eine Platte kaputt. Ja, dann hat das System auch erstmal das Richtige getan. Die Daten waren ja sozusagen noch vollständig auf den anderen Platten enthalten oder sollten sie zumindest sein. Hab die Platte rausgenommen, hab die dem Händler wieder zurückgegeben und hab gesagt, die ist kaputt. Ich meinte, glaubt er nicht, aber es ist egal, tauschen wir trotzdem um, weil die muss ich wahrscheinlich nur neu formatieren und dann kann ich sie wieder verkaufen. Dann hab ich die neue eingesetzt und hat er offenbar getan.
Du selber hast sie nicht getestet, die du rausgenommen hast.
Ich hab so wenig Zeit, ich kann hier auch noch anfangen, irgendwelche Platten zu testen. Und vor allem, was kann ich schon groß testen? Ich kann irgendwie testen, dass sie jetzt so ein bisschen funktioniert und dann stecke ich denen ein Drobo rein und dann sagt, der ist kaputt. Also wem soll ich dann glauben? Ich bin jetzt mal davon ausgegangen, dass dieses Gerät das irgendwie halbwegs hinkriegt. Dann hab ich also die neue Platte reingesteckt und wurde auch irgendwie dann zur Kenntnis genommen und dann hat er da irgendwie wieder drauf rumverteilt. Die Drobo-Lämpchen, die leuchten anders, wenn er da so umschaufelt.
Steht auf der Kiste drauf.
Genau, es gibt ja so verschiedene Zustände, die sind auch in diesem leicht abnehmbaren Deckel immer wieder dokumentiert. Grün ist also, alles ist prima. Orange ist, wenn die, also ist sozusagen der Vorschlag, dass man doch mal eine Platte austauschen sollte, wobei sie jetzt hier gerade nicht sagen, ob es jetzt wegen Speicher ist oder wegen, könnte kaputt gehen. Dann Don't Remove Drei, so grün, orange, grün. Das ist sozusagen, wenn du also sozusagen eine Redundanz herstellen musst, du hast eine Platte reingepackt oder sonst, irgendwas wird hin und her geschaufelt. Rot heißt, jetzt musst du hier mal unbedingt eine Platte reintun und wenn sie rot leuchtet, dann irgendwie solltest du halt da eine kaputte Platte austauschen. Oh, jetzt bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, hat die eigentlich rot geleuchtet oder rot geblinkt? Das hat er mir nur gesagt, dass ich die Drive hier reintun soll. Hm, vielleicht war das nur ein Kontaktproblem.
Robo, doch gar nicht so schlecht, Tim hat sich vertan.
Naja, pass mal auf. So, dann ging es richtig zur Sache. Ich habe also so hin und her kopiert, das Ding hat so eine Woche in Betrieb gehabt und auf einmal habe ich ihn wieder angeschlossen und er meinte, Fallsystem ist irgendwie korrupt, habe ich die als Read-Only gemountet. Ich so, hm, habe abgezogen, angesteckt, blieb so. Er hat da irgendwie rumgerudelt und meinte irgendwie, Fallsystem ist korrupt, musst du mal irgendwie reparieren. Disk-Utility gestartet, First Aid, findet ja in der Regel immer irgendwas. First Aid ist gleich ausgestiegen, meint, viel zu kaputt, kann ich nichts machen. Weier dachte ich mir so, das kann ja wohl nicht dein Ernst sein. Wie bitte kann es sein, dass dieses Fallsystem korrupt ist? Es ist auch nicht so, dass mein Rechner jetzt irgendwie 30.000 Mal gecrasht wäre oder sonst irgendwas. Das ist auch gar keine Daten, die jetzt aktiv die ganze Zeit geschrieben wurden oder benutzt wurden oder so. Das war ein Archiv. Es war einfach korrupt. Da dachte ich mir, das kann wohl nicht euer Ernst sein. Hab ich Disk-Warrior wieder ausgegraben. Du weißt, das ist so diese Last-Resort-Tool, wenn irgendwie gar nichts mehr geht, was aber bisher in den letzten zehn Jahren meines Lebens, gibt es das schon seit zehn Jahren, weiß nicht, seit vielen Jahren, mir eigentlich alle bis auf eine einzige Platte, die wohl wirklich im Arsch war, gerettet hat.
Man hat ein Problem, wenn man Disk-Warrior braucht, aber dann hat man noch einen Hauch einer Chance, da wenigstens irgendwas runterzulegen.
Disk-Warrior ist wirklich ein cooles Tool. Also wer wirklich mal Fallsystem-Fuck-Up hat, bevor man aufgibt, kauft man sich Disk-Warrior, wirft das dran drauf. Disk-Warrior hat eine kluge Methode, ein Directory-System wieder herzustellen. Also wenn das sozusagen wirklich nur kaputte Fallsystemstruktur ist, der sucht einfach mit klugen Algorithmen so sehr nach allem und nach der ursprünglichen Struktur und baut die dann komplett neu zusammen. Das heißt, er repariert nicht, wie das diese Norton-Tools machen, sondern er baut ein frisches Directory auf und schreibt das an eine andere unbenutzte Stelle der Platte und linkt das dann am Anfang entsprechend um. Das ist ein wirklich sehr zuverlässiger Vorgang, hat aber bei diesem Drobo nichts bewirkt. Ich hab das Ding 24 Stunden da dran gehabt, er kam mir dann irgendwie mit Fehlermeldungen hoch und nachdem er meinte, er hätte jetzt 1.100.000 Disk-Errors gefunden, dachte ich mir so, hier ist doch was faul.
Konntest du denn Daten noch öffnen von der Platte?
Die konnte ich da schon so noch runterlesen. Da ich die aber zu dem Zeitpunkt noch alle auf meinen alten Archivplatten hatten, habe ich jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne einen Datenverlust gehabt. Aber ob die jetzt wirklich alle in Ordnung waren, weiß ich nicht. Weil wenn der mir jetzt sagt, das Fallsystem ist im Arsch, dann klingt das einfach mal nicht gut. Und ich hatte da jetzt auch wenig Musse, das zu überprüfen. Was sozusagen zu einem zweiten Problem führte, was ich mit diesem Drobo gehabt habe. Ich habe nämlich jetzt diese erste Version eben mit 4 oder 8 Terabyte, keine Ahnung, mit irgendeinem Future-Compatible- Größe gemacht und habe mir nichts weiter dabei gedacht. Dann habe ich das Ding, nachdem ich alle Daten drauf kopiert habe, an meine Time Capsule angeschlossen, über USB. Weil meine Idee ist, erstens, ich will die Daten, die regelmäßigen Time Capsule Backups, die ich da habe, sozusagen nochmal back-upen. Und außerdem noch über dieses Disk Sharing von der Time Capsule auf den Drobo zugreifen und das so als Dauerarchiv verwenden. So für Sachen, die man nicht mehr braucht, wo ich aber so eine gewisse Reliability haben will und vor allem, wo ich dieses Gerät nehmen kann und irgendwo anders hin tun kann, wenn ich es mal sichern will. Und naja, jetzt wurde es wirklich komisch, weil die Platte wurde zwar erkannt von der Time Capsule, aber ich konnte da nicht wirklich so drauf zugreifen und er meinte auch irgendwie was, das wäre eine 256 GB Platte. Ich konnte allerdings über das Filesharing schon drauf zugreifen. Ich hab mich gewundert, hab mal so ein bisschen nach Drobo und Time Capsule gesucht und dann kamen irgendwie 1000 FAQs hoch, die mir erzählen, ach ja, übrigens die Time Capsule kann nur Fallsysteme bis zwei Terabyte schreiben. Also die Time Capsule hat irgendein albernes Limit im HFS-Zugriff und kann nur bis zwei Terabyte. Womit ich natürlich jetzt sozusagen meine ganze ursprüngliche Planung, wofür ich das verwenden wollte, was für so ein Backup-System nicht perfekt ist. Sie haben da eine Terabyte-Platte drin, warum brauchen Sie mehr als zwei Terabyte? Ich dachte, ich sterbe. Es ging wirklich gar nicht. Diese Probleme mit den Daten kamen übrigens später. Ich habe das vorher angeschlossen. So, dann war es kurz vor Weihnachten und dann war ich im Süden und bin nach München gefahren und habe mir den neuen Apple Store angeschaut und habe dann mal die Crew von dem Apple Store mit meinem Problem belegt. Die waren eigentlich sehr überlastet, aber dann trotzdem extrem freundlich und haben mir zumindest versprochen, dann irgendwann mal per E-Mail Rückmeldung zu geben. Die gab es auch, wurde also auch nicht fallen gelassen. Allerdings gab es zu diesem 2 Terabyte-Limit da keine Aussage. Ich werde da jetzt nochmal nachhaken oder habe schon nachgehakt.
Das ist halt ein 32 Bit-Limit, weil 4 Milliarden mal 512 Bytes, weil so groß hinter die Blöcke, ergibt genau 2 Terabyte. Schlechte Software, uralt.
Was läuft auf der Type-Cup-Show?
NetBSD. Wahrscheinlich ein komplett veralteter HFS-Treiber, oder?
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich von Apple.
Ja, sollte das sein, oder?
Ja, ich meine, wenn Apple nicht in der Lage ist, auf einem BSD-Unix, ein HFS-Körner, ich meine...
Das sollte mit Make machbar sein.
Ja, also da fällt mir nun wirklich nichts ein, was sie davon abhalten sollte, 64-Bit-Strukturen zu lesen. I don't know, also das ist mir wirklich ein Rätsel. Und das ist wirklich bekloppt. Dann habe ich Folgendes gemacht, ich habe das Ding neu formatiert, nachdem der ganze Stress da war. Und man kann sozusagen... Na ja, man kann nicht wirklich... Ja, also man kann nicht wirklich partitionieren. Aber du kannst mehrere Drives machen. Das heißt, wenn du sagst, ich will aber nur zwei Terabyte Volume, dann legt er dir tatsächlich zwei Drives an. Die sich aber auch wirklich als zwei Drives melden und nicht als eine Drive mit zwei Partitionen. Und das geht jetzt an der Time Capsule, das kann man machen. Und man kann auch wirklich das Backup da wegschreiben. Und so geht das. Das heißt, jetzt habe ich da irgendwie zwei Disks, zwei virtuelle Disks, sage ich mal, die virtuell zwei Terabyte groß sind.
Die insgesamt vier Terabyte groß sind.
Die insgesamt sich aber aus 2,7 Netto Platz, genau, oder 4 Terabyte Brutto-Speisen, die habe ich da halt irgendwie beisammen. Na ja.
Was war denn jetzt aber das Problem?
Und dann habe ich noch mal das Ding, einmal beim Umdingsen, gab es auch noch das Problem, dass die eine Platte nicht anlief. Und ich die erst wieder rausnehmen und wieder reinschieben musste, bevor ich die dann auch noch genommen habe.
Weißt du, was das Problem war jetzt?
Welches Problem? Mit dem Fallsystem? Keine Ahnung.
Weil ehrlich gesagt, also ich meine, eine Bäcker-Platte würde das ja mein Vertrauen komplett zerstören, wenn ich dann nach drei Minuten das Detailsystem umarsche, ohne dass ich den Grund dafür kenne.
Also ich hatte auch jetzt nicht das Gefühl, den großen Drobo-Sermon einleiten zu müssen. Also wenn man hier so regelmäßige Erhörer von twitch.tv, hier MrLeoLaporteLiebtAlles ist, da wird ja dieser Drobo rauf und runter gelobt, bis es irgendwie gar nicht mehr geht. Dann gibt es diesen schönen Song, den er immer gerne einspielt, immer dieses Put all of your stuff on a Drobo, der sehr schön ist. Und mir kam dann immer nur so, Lose all of your stuff on a Drobo.
Aber das mit den größeren Platten, aber guck mal, das wäre doch tatsächlich, könnten die das doch relativ einfach lösen, wenn dieses Drobo-Tool oder wie auch immer, wenn es dir einfach auf den Bereich, den du sowieso nicht beschreiben kannst, weil da gar keine Festplatte liegt, wenn sie dir einfach eine unsichtbare Datei drauf packen und schon ist nur noch so und so viel Platz auf der Platte frei, schon läufst du nicht mehr Gefahr, dass du Daten wegschreibst in eine Richtung, wo es gar nicht hingeht und schon kann damit die Time Machine umgehen ohne Probleme.
Das ist eine interessante Variante. Dann müsste das Ding aber schon, das erfordert aber sozusagen schon eine gewisse Intelligenz, auch noch so eine Datei vorzutäuschen.
Ja, aber das könnte ja noch sogar dieses Dashboard-Tool machen. Das könnte ja einfach sagen, du, ich schreib dir jetzt gleich eine Datei hin.
Naja, das Dashboard-Tool kann ja, du willst das ja auch an den Rechner anschließen, wo du eben diesen Spezialtrailer nicht hinstellst.
Die muss ja nur einmal angelegt werden, die Datei. Die muss ja exakt einmal angelegt und wenn sie einmal da ist, dann am besten mit Schreibschutz versehen werden.
Dann machen wir uns nicht künstlich seine Platte wieder kleiner, weil die das nicht hinkriegen, oder was?
Ja, aber wenn du deine Platten tauscht, dann muss das ja sozusagen auch automatisch gemacht werden, ohne dass du es nochmal an so ein komisches Dashboard anschließt.
Also auf jeden Fall würde ich für die bessere Lösung halten.
Irgendwas muss man irgendwie machen. Also hier im Chat wird jetzt schon gefragt, ist der Drobo zu empfehlen oder nicht? Um ehrlich zu sein, ich weiß es nicht. Ich kenne eine Menge Leute, die haben ganz gute Erfahrungen damit gehabt, aber eigentlich ist das Problem ist HFS.
So sieht es nämlich aus.
Das ist eigentlich nicht dafür gemacht. Und da kommt jetzt wirklich dieses ZFS noch mal ins Spiel, denn ZFS löst diese Probleme. Eigentlich will man so ein, also die Hardware ist ja geil, also so ein Teil, wo man einfach mal so vier SATA-Platten rein und raus zackern kann. Das ist gut, aber die sollten sozusagen beim Rechner auch einfach als vier SATA-Platten ankommen. Wäre mal schön, wenn unsere Macs mal E-SATA hätten zum Beispiel. Nur das gibt es so nicht und dann brauchst du eben auch noch die entsprechende Software. Diese Software ist erfunden, die heißt ZFS, die muss jetzt erstmal stabilisiert werden. Läuft das jetzt alles stabil auf dem Mac? Ich habe gehört, bei FreeBSD gibt es noch richtig Kernelpanics.
Nee, also auf dem Mac ist es immer noch eine uralt Version, die haben das schon seit Juli, glaube ich, keine neue Version mehr rausgebracht. Die Aktuelle ist die 119, also so wie Apple die Versionen durchnummeriert, die sind da aber halt total hinterher. Versprochen ist eine neue, ist aber bisher nichts gekommen und ein Grund davon ist auch, weil die schon wieder so viele Änderungen vornehmen müssen, auch am OS, dass das auf dem Leopard gar nicht mehr laufen würde, deswegen kommt wahrscheinlich keine Beta-Version mehr von ZFS, weil wir das Snow Leopard passend dazu nicht mehr haben, deswegen, glaube ich, können die gar nichts mehr rausrücken, gerade so hat es es jedenfalls erklärt, diese Noel de la Fano, oder wie sie heißt. Auf FreeBSD ist alles total super, rock'n'roll, stable. In der Version 8.0 Current, die gibt es halt noch nicht selbst als stable, aber das ZFS da drin, finde ich, ist ziemlich gut. Und jetzt kommt es, seit dem 20. November hat FreeBSD auch Support, dass man nativ von ZFS booten kann, also man braucht gar kein UFS oder sonst irgendwie Pfeilsystem mehr, wo man sein Coilnol herholt, sondern der FreeBSD Loader kann jetzt den Coilnol direkt vom ZFS holen oder auch von einem ZFS Mürrerstripe. Und bei FreeBSD schaffen sie es sogar, weil sie nämlich schon alle Platten sehen. Man kann sein Coilnol sogar von einem ZFS Raid irgendwie, also so ein Raid-Z irgendwie sich laden lassen, was auch nicht mal auf Solaris geht, weil der noch beim Coilnol-Hochfahren nicht alle Platten sieht. Und deswegen geht das mit dem Raid-Z nicht. Und ich habe an Sylvester irgendwie den ganzen Tag geklickt, weil Kumpel NerdKrüx hat gesagt, man kann jetzt FreeBSD-ZFS booten. Ich habe gewartet, bis der das alle durchpuppelt, weil er irgendwie besser testhart wird. Und dann habe ich an Sylvester tagsüber meinen Router hier komplett neu installiert auf zwei Mal 1TB ZFS-Mirror. Und seitdem ist meine Kiste rock'n'roll super geil, weil vorher so ein Game-Mirror irgendwie stürzt dein Rechner ab, da musst du erst mal stundenlang dein Mirror rebuilden. Gleichzeitig läuft der F-Check im Hintergrund. Der Plattenkopf würde, wenn du ihn nicht abbrechst, dabei würde er stundenlang hin und her rattern, also würde nichts vorwärts gehen. Und jetzt mit so ZFS hatte ich letztens auch einen Panic, aber nicht wegen ZFS, sondern wegen IPv6, Schnickschnack. Und da boot ich einfach den Rechner und der weiß, dass sofort alles voll toll ist. Alles ist gecheckt und du hast ein voll gutes Gefühl. Also ZFS ist einfach geil.
Ich muss dazu noch eine Anmerkung machen. Klickt doch mal auf wiki.freebsd.org/großzfsund dann... wiki.freebsd.org/zfsknownproblems.
Also hier known problems gotchas für ZFS. Das ist richtig, man muss sein K-Mem ein bisschen hochdrehen und das war's aber auch schon.
Dann steht hier noch heavy IO-Activity zwischen ZFS und anderen Fallsystemen kann in Deadlocks resultieren.
Hatt ich bisher noch nicht und ich hab da 300 Gigabyte Musik gleich erstmal drauf geschoben. Also meine beiden Terabytes, also ist ja ein Terabyte übrig wegen Mörrer, ist schon zur Hälfte voll und da ist alles super sauber und easy. Und mein Rechner ist sogar unterhalb das, was die für ZFS empfehlen, weil ich hab nur zweimal 700 Megahertz und nur 512 Megabyte RAM. Und man soll irgendwie wohl dem K-Mem schon 512 zuweisen, was ich gar nicht hab, weil ich insgesamt nur 512 hab. Das heißt, ich fahre voll unter Limit und es rocken wohl stabil. Also es ist einfach super. Na ich buete ja jetzt davon. Ich meine, alles die ganze Zeit ist irgendwie bei mir ZFS. Ich hab schon die Ports installiert, hab schon den Source runtergeladen. Ich hab Filesystems, wo ich GZIP-Compression einschalte, obwohl meine Kiste so böse langsam ist. Also die Ports zum Beispiel sind alle bei mir mit GZIP. Die User Source, wo die Kernelsourcen drin liegen, ist bei mir mit dem Standard-Compression, was nicht ganz so gut ist, aber dafür auch ein bisschen schneller. Und ich hab schon für meine User eigene Filesystems angelegt. Also für jeden neuen Scheiß mach ich mir gleich sofort ein Filesystem. Ich hab alles schon gesnapshotted. Und es funktioniert einfach. Nein.
Also auf dem Mac hab ich hier gerade per Twitter...
WSD läuft aber auch auf dem Mac.
Also, ich hab hier neulich...
Auf der Hardware.
Ja, also man könnte sich ein Mac mini nehmen.
Nee, und ab Mac OS sehen.
Gibt's da Firewire irgendwie?
Also ich hab hier gerade neulich einen schönen Dialog gelesen, auf Twitter, also das erste Nachricht von Roddy. Dieses ständige Körnige Panic von ZFS nervt gewaltig. Kein Wunder, dass Apple das noch nicht released hat. Dann Antwort von Twitter.
Welche Vision hat er denn?
Dann die Antwort von Hessey, der ja bei Bits und so der große Befürworter ist, den ich auch neulich kennengelernt hab. Roddy, wie kommst du denn zu deinen Panics? Im Prinzip ist ZFS OS X ziemlich stabil mit wenigen reproduzierbaren Kernel Panics.
Ich werd gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass die letzte Editierung von dieser Webseite vom 17. Juni 2008 ist.
Nächste Antwort.
Der Super Patch kam Ende Juli raus für 8.0 und das war erst mal ein Patch und der wurde erst im Oktober oder sowas. Also erst sozusagen seit jetzt ist alles super toll.
Nächste Antwort. Wenn man richtig Lust macht, Panic das bei mir nach etwa drei Stunden, zum Beispiel Ubuntu und Solaris, gleichzeitig in je einer VM installieren. Du bist jetzt wieder bei der Mac-Version, richtig? Genau. Dann Antwort von Roddy, von Hessey wiederum. Gut, ich zieh meinen Kommentar zurück. Das ist genau einer der zwei Fälle, in denen ich auch eine Kernel Panic schaffe. Hohe Lust.
Ja gut, OS X ist ja noch mal ein anderes Ding. Wir reden ja eigentlich von Freebies.
Die Antwort dann, lass mich raten. Der andere Fall ist, Laufwerk ohne Unmounten entfernen. Also auf dem Mac ist es offensichtlich noch nicht so doll.
Ja, it's not ready yet. Ich meine, da sind wir jetzt noch nicht, aber bei Freebies, die... Okay, Denis, also du sagst, es ist stabil.
Also mein Router läuft seit jetzt Silvester rock'n'roll und ist zumindest wegen ZFS noch nie abgestürzt.
Kann man denn so eine Lösung wie der Drovo eigentlich mit ZFS machen? Also könnte man ein System machen, wo wirklich das Unmounten der Platte sozusagen kontrolliert vor sich geht? Eigentlich bräuchte man ja eine spezielle Hardware, wo man...
Was meinste, mit Unmounten kontrolliert?
Na ja, wenn ich so eine Platte aus dem Pool rausnehme irgendwie.
Also wenn ich jetzt aus meinem Rechner eine Platte rausziehe, dann macht er einfach weiter, weil er ist ein Mörrer, und dann sagt er, da fehlt halt eine Platte, würde ein bisschen rumheulen, aber er würde weitermachen. Und wenn ich sie da reinstecke, würde er automatisch irgendwie die wieder re-silvern, weil er sofort weiß, was da fehlt, weil die da so diesen Merkel-Tree haben und die Shacks um so durch den Baum wandern und er findet sofort raus, was denn in diesem Mörrer-Teil... Dass er den Mörrer wieder neu baut. So eine normale Raid-Karten, die du auch kaufen kannst, hier mit diesem Mörrer-System, kippst du ja alles irgendwie. Wenn du da die Platte rausziehst und dann wieder irgendwie reinsteckst später, dann weißt er halt nicht, was denn nun wo geschrieben wurde. Er muss eigentlich den kompletten Mörrer noch mal neu machen, weil er halt keine Ahnung hat vom Inhalt. Weil er muss halt einen Block für den anderen wieder durchmörrern. Das ZFS hat aber Ahnung von dem Mörrer. Und der wandert halt seinen Check so einen Baum da durch und findet sofort raus, was nicht geschrieben werden konnte auf die zweite Platte. Und machte das in 0, nichts wieder heile. Und F-Check gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Das wäre wirklich mal eine wertvolle Recherche, dass man wirklich mal ein bisschen zusammenträgt, was man da eigentlich am besten an Hardware sich zusammenbaut, um eine halbwegs kompakte, leise Lösung für den Wohnzimmerschrank zu haben.
Na, ein Ding ist halt, man geht auf richtig Nummer sicher und holt sich irgendwie so ein Minimaschinen-X86-Mäßig und installiert sich da ein Open Solaris. Weil bei denen ist es wirklich rock'n'roll stabil, weil die liefern das schon seit, weiß nicht, wie viele Monaten oder einem Jahr schon irgendwie aus und haben auch Native-Boot davon und so weiter und so fort. Und die kümmern sich auch. Und ich glaube, da gab es in der letzten CT oder IX, oder ich glaube, es war die CT, gab es irgendwie so Artikel, wie man sich so ein Open Solaris-Rechnerchen zusammenschraubt. Und das ist dann automatisch mit ZFS. Und die haben auch schon so Admin-Tools, glaube ich, so mit GUI irgendwie, wo man so ein bisschen verwalten kann, das ZFS.
Ich habe auch gelesen, ich habe mal Open Solaris, worauf es so läuft, geklickt. Und da gibt es auch Berichte von Läuft auf Mac Mini.
Ja, dann, zack!
Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob es da auch Firewire-Treiber gibt.
Ja, das weiß ich halt auch nicht.
Gibt es bei FreeBSD Firewire-Treiber?
Äh, ich glaube schon, probiert habe ich es noch nicht. Mein Rechner hat halt kein Firewire. Aber eigentlich gibt es da schon, klar, doch, zum Club gibt es auch Leute, die da Firewire dran haben. C-Punkt hat Firewire an seinem FreeBSD. Er hat auch extra eine Karte dafür sich geholt irgendwie mal. Ich glaube, das war sogar für sein iPod, ich weiß gar nicht so genau.
Naja, müsste man sich irgendwie so machen. Der Drobo ist auf jeden Fall, sagen wir mal so, die schnelle Lösung. Ich habe jetzt hier so ein bisschen Stress gehabt. Ich will jetzt noch kein vernichtendes Urteil brechen, allerdings problemlos war das nicht. Und ich habe keine Ahnung, warum dieses Fallsystem kaputt gegangen ist.
Das ist ja auch das Problem an dem Drobo, warum die das nicht fixen können. Weil wenn die bei Drobo gar nicht schuld sind, dass dein Filesystem kaputt geht, dann ist dein Filesystem schuld. So, wenn die von Drobo aber nur die Hardware liefern und du erstmal nichts weiter hast, außer da irgendwie einen HFS schon drauf zu installieren und dann auch nur irgendwie schon mit komisch Größen festlegen, dann ist das doch irgendwie Müll. Du willst eigentlich ein cooles Filesystem da drauf haben. Und was sollte man da machen?
Naja, man muss jetzt wahrscheinlich erst mal warten, bis dieses coole Filesystem auch verfügbar ist. Aber das mit Open Solaris auf so einer Box ist vielleicht ganz gut. Aber das ist natürlich dann auch nicht fad.
Aber wie greift man dann da drauf zu? Also wie kriege ich da einen Backup drauf?
Das ist dann die nächste Frage. Wie greift man darauf zu?
Du machst da halt auch Netatalk, SMB oder...
Na SMB gibt es schon da Teilnahmprobleme.
Ja, es gibt Netatalk.
Also wie gesagt, mit Netatalk habe ich irgendwann mal so schlimme Erfahrungen gemacht, dass ich es fast nicht mehr einsetzen würde.
Ja, aber wann war das?
Das ist ewig lange her, das stimmt schon.
Das ist seitdem besser geworden. Und das soll schon funktionieren. Es gibt übrigens für den Drobo ja auch noch so eine Erweiterung, das Drobo Share. Das ist so eine kleine Box, die du da drunter stellst. Die hat dann Internet und schließt dich selber über USB oder Firewire an. Also wahrscheinlich Firewire, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht nachgeschaut. Wie auch immer, das Ding hat dann Ethernet und shared halt und out of the box kann es halt SMB, was lame ist, aber es gibt offiziell die Erlaubnis, darauf sozusagen Software-Pakete zu installieren und da ist letztlich Linux drauf. Und es gibt jemanden, der irgendwo auf CodeGoogle kommt, gibt es ein Projekt, wo sie halt NetArt-Hawk für den Drobo Share anbieten und meinen, sie wären voll Time Machine-kompatibel im Sinne von wird von Time Machine als valides Volume erkannt. Bleibt natürlich nach wie vor dieses Problem, was ich eben schon besprochen habe, mit der Größe, aber grundsätzlich...
Das bleibt trotzdem bestehen?
Das ändert ja nichts daran. Das Volume hat halt eine bestimmte Größe, von der es behauptet, dass es sozusagen da ist, aber der...
Spätestens, wenn er einen AFP-Server kann, könnte der doch andere Größen übermitteln. Also ich meine, das gibt es ja nun bei AFP auf jeden Fall, dass da irgendwelche Quote da ist.
Ja, könnte vielleicht. Ich hab's nicht getestet, ich hab keinen Drobo Share, ich hab das jetzt nur im Web gesehen, dass der Typ von sich behauptet, dass das Stable sei und funktionieren würde. Und das könne man sich halt einfach so installieren und dann wäre alles toll. Aber ehrlich gesagt, mir fehlen da selber jetzt die Erfahrungen.
Also was mir jetzt so beim ersten Anlehnensetzen negativ aufgefallen ist, relativ laut das Ding. Also ich weiß nicht, ob so was viel leiser geht, aber... Ja, aber es ist, also der Lüfter läuft, und also es ist nichts, was ich jetzt unbedingt irgendwo...
Nee, das Ding ist leise. Mal ehrlich. Also wenn er nichts zu tun hat, dann wird der sehr leise. Und wenn er zu tun hat, sind das immerhin vier Platten, die hier irgendwie gelüftet werden müssen. Da muss man auch mal blasen.
Nee, ich sag ja gar nicht, dass es prinzipiell nicht anders ginge, oder dass das nicht vielleicht ein prinzipielles Problem ist. Aber ich hatte so, ich hatte so gedacht, okay, das ist jetzt so dieses, gerade mit dem Share-Ding, da stellt man sich irgendwo in den Schrank, vielleicht auch nicht gerade, oder auf den Schrank, und da arbeitet das dann leise vor sich hin. Und richtig leise ist es nicht, jedenfalls nicht beim Zug auf...
Es sind nach wie vor vier Platten, wo sich vier Sachen bewegen. Ich kann ja auch gerne mal hier meine vier externe Festplatten-Gehäuse, meine vier Ferien anmachen, da läuft so aber davon. Also im Vergleich dazu ist der Drobo echt okay.
Was hast du denn für Platten drin? Hast du diese Green-Platten gekauft? Ich habe mir zweimal so eine Green-Dinger gekauft, die total leise sind und wenig Strom...
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob dieses Green-Level tragen kann sein. Das sind diese Samsung, die nur 5400 machen. Ich glaube, das ist das.
Ich habe mir Western Digital Green gekauft. 85 Euro die Platte, voll billig. Ja, 2x1TB habe ich geschoppt.
Der ist doch riesengroß, also der sollte schon das leise sein, was geht, aber ich fand ihn...
Dafür sind sie halt nicht schnell, aber ich konnte trotzdem da irgendwie mit einem 25-Mio-Postest.
Okay, aber jetzt werden wir ja schon so ein Verkaufsgespräch führen, ne? Dann sag doch mal, was kostet denn jetzt so ein Drobo, weil der wird ja ohne Platten verkauft, richtig?
Genau, 450 kostet er.
150 Euro? 450? Ohne Platten? Holy moly shit. Also ich hätte mir für 450, ich weiß nicht, was kostet ein Gehäuse irgendwie, wo vier Platten reingehen, die aber alle einzeln dann am Rechner ankommen? Gibt es doch irgendwie auch, oder? Gibt es sowas? Mit zweien gibt es doch sowas aber auf jeden Fall. Davon hätte ich mir dann irgendwie zwei Stücke holt, irgendwie mit Firefire Daisy Chained. Da hätte ich schon mal irgendwie vier Platten an meinem Mac und dann würde ich die schön alle irgendwie einzeln bedingten.
Denis, lass uns so eine Box bauen, lass uns irgendwie einen FreeBSD nehmen mit einer ordentlichen ZFS-Konfiguration, die sich irgendwie halbwegs bequem administrieren lässt, wo irgendwie wir suchen uns ein schickes Gehäuse und sorgen dafür, dass NetAttack da drüber läuft und dass da irgendwie Time Machine richtig geht und dass das mit der Volumengröße irgendwie ordentlich kommuniziert wird und dass das Ding möglichst auch noch, wenn man eine Platte rausnimmt, die automatisch die Redundanz auf den Platten anpasst, wenn man neue rein macht, automatisch übernimmt und dann hast du quasi Drobo nachgebaut.
Dann habe ich noch eine kurze Frage zu dem Time Machine 2TB Problem. Das war jetzt nur von der Time Capsule Problem. Okay, das Time Machine selbst hat damit keine Probleme. Nehme ich mal an. Ich habe ja bei meinem Router schon, ich habe ja da das ZFS drauf, habe da irgendwie schon lauter Filesystems. Da kann ich ja die größte Bestimmung im ZFS, weil du kannst ja Quotas, Reservations und Limits und lauter Zeug setzen und so. Es geht ja alles schon. Und einen NetAttack habe ich ja auch schon drauf. Da könnte ich mir jetzt halt einen so ein Filesystem hier per NetAttack exportieren für meinen Laptop hier, für meinen Mac. Aber man muss da glaube ich noch ein bisschen rumbasseln, bevor das Time Machine das auch annimmt, oder? Aber der findet das dann immer noch nicht, wenn ich meinen Rechner einschalte, der findet es dann auch nicht so von ganz alleine, so wie er einen Time Capsule erkennt. Oder ich muss den schon von Hand mountainen, bevor der dann da loslegt.
Das ist einst ein Problem, es sei denn, man ist komplett kompatibel zu einer Time Capsule und meldet sich als solcher auch an.
Dafür gibt es ja bestimmt wieder so einen Bonjour-Tricks, oder?
Genau.
Ich glaube, da muss ich mir auch schon mal das wechseln.
Die sind aber relativ einfach. Da nimmst du halt irgendwie Avahi oder so und dann kannst du eben auch sowas ausprobieren.
Nimmst du einmal mit und da gibt es ja bei Freeways ja auch dieses Bonjour-Avahi, glaube ich, inzwischen auch schon.
Mir würden da noch ein paar andere Tricks einfallen. Ich will das jetzt auch nicht weiter vertiefen, müssen wir noch mal einen kleinen Themenwechsel machen. Wir reden jetzt schon ziemlich lange darüber. Aber was halt eigentlich der große Fehler ist, bei Mac OS X, wo ich hoffe, dass Snowlipper das noch behebt, weil sie hatten es in der ursprünglichen Beta-Version von Time Machine mal drin, dass man halt in verschlüsselte Disc-Images schreiben kann. Also dass das Backup nicht verschlüsselt ist, ist eine echte Unterlassung von Apple. Und auch da wäre es halt schön, wenn man eine Lösung hätte mit dem ZFS, dass man eben Krypto benutzt.
Nee, der Pawel, der das da macht bei FreeBSD, der hat die Anfragen natürlich auch schon und der hat gesagt, er wird natürlich erst dann das Krypto in FreeBSD einbauen, wenn sie es bei OBSolaris oder bei Solaris halt überhaupt erst mal haben. Und die haben es ja auch noch nicht. Ach so. Die sind zwar schon fast mehr oder weniger fertig damit, haben es aber noch nicht offiziell rausgegeben. Und ihr geplantes Release dafür ist die Open Solaris Version 109. Und sie sind gerade, lass mich gucken, die letzten Tage waren sie noch bei 104. Die kommen so alle zwei Wochen, kommt bei denen eine neue Version raus. Und das heißt, wenn sie fünf Versionen noch hinterher sind, kommt es in zweieinhalb Monaten. Genau, sie sind noch bei 104 und bei 109 soll es kommen.
Was man aber vielleicht cool machen könnte, wäre, dass man auf dem ZFS-Storage ein Disk-Image hat, so ein Sparse-Bundle, was gekryptet ist. Und dass dann auf der Büchse selber einer, man muss ja den Key in der Büchse haben, das hat ja auch ein bisschen bekloppt. Aber dass man sozusagen das Net-ATOC so konfiguriert, dass es nur dieses Disk-Image als Share rausgibt sozusagen.
Ob das geht?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Na ja, jetzt haben wir auch genug Zeit verdödet mit Drobo und Balala. Also ich kann kein abschließendes Urteil fällen. Dazu haben wir einfach zu wenig getänktet.
Ich finde es ganz schön teuer dafür, dass du nur so komisch da ein File-System draufkriegst, wo du da nicht mal richtig partizipieren kannst.
Aber es ist ein Gerät, wo du eben nicht mit einer Shell draufgehen musst, um dein File-System zu konfigurieren, sondern du sagst halt einfach hier, ich nehme jetzt hier diese Platte raus und stecke da eine größere rein und dann kümmert er sich eigenständig darum, dass die Daten da draufmigriert werden und es wird halt auch einfach automatisch alles größer.
Also mit dieser überdimensional großen Platte, das finde ich ein bisschen doof.
Ja, ich auch.
Und was mir jetzt gerade noch auffällt, und das ist wiederum eine prinzipielle Sache, aber wenn man so einen kleinen Kasten, den man glaube ich auch beim Umzug gerne unter dem Arm nimmt oder sowas, also die größte Gefahr für so Datenverluste ist ja immer noch die Physik. Und mir ist nämlich neulich eine Festplatte gestorben, bei im laufenden Betrieb einfach auf die Seite kippen. Wenn einem die Kiste hier im laufenden Betrieb auf die Seite kippt, ist ja die Gefahr ziemlich hoch, dass man nicht nur eine Platte kaputt hat, sondern dass man gleich drei hat, oder zwei.
Der goldene Spruch ist ja, ein RAID ist kein Backup. Auch wenn du ein System hast, was ein RAID ist, dann sind deine Daten an sich zwar sicherer, aber ein Backup musst du trotzdem machen. Ja ok, aber dann ist es ja auch schon die zweite Instanz deiner Daten, wenn es schon ein Backup ist. Aber wenn man, also man hat seine Daten nicht nur auf so einem Gerät. Dann ist es auch nicht schlimm, wenn es mal umfällt.
Klar, also bei mir ist es Secondary Backup. Also bei mir ist es das Backup von Backup. Und dafür finde ich es halt cool, weil man kann irgendwie auch Sachen auslagern, die man selten braucht. Und man kann das Ding halt irgendwie auch mal wegschließen, wenn man irgendwie länger weg ist.
Wir greifen das halt bei der nächsten Sendung wieder auf, wenn wir ein bisschen mehr herausgefunden haben, wie ich hier bei ZF, das Netatalk, das so mit dem Time Machine Zeugchen kriege.
Wir haben noch kein Wort gesagt, über Yellow Snow.
Jaja, das droht jetzt noch. Das ist sozusagen unser letztes Thema, würde ich sagen.
Habt ihr denn Special Informations?
Special nicht, aber...
Ich hab den Vortrag gesehen.
Den hab ich auch gesehen.
Worüber reden wir? Auf dem 25. Chaos-Communication-Kongress in Berlin vom Chaos Computer Club, blablabla, Sie wissen schon, war halt das iPhone Dev Team da. Die Jungs saßen da vorne auf der Bühne und haben sich kurz vorher das allererste Mal überhaupt getroffen, sagten sie ja auch.
Und waren wahrscheinlich genauso überrascht wie wir.
Genau. Und mich erinnerte also diese Truppe, wie sie da vorne saß, erinnerte mich so an diese, diese uralten US-Serien mit dieser Kinderbande da auf der Straße mit dem Hund und so, wo die irgendwie alle so unterschiedlich groß und breit und unterschiedlich aussahen.
So die verschiedenen Typen noch, die man zusammenfischt hat?
Ja, so 40er Jahre, USA.
Dann kommst du jetzt wegen dem Muscle Nerd drauf, oder?
Ja, also da war der Chinese, vier Typen waren irgendwie auf der Bühne, die sahen alle irgendwie komplett anders aus. Und einer war ja Muscle Nerd. Und man wusste einfach sofort, wer Muscle Nerd war, weil Muscle Nerd saß im Muscle-Shirt auf der Bühne und der hatte einfach extrem Muskeln.
Der hat Oberarme, da ist mein Körperschlank gegen.
Man fragt sich, wie er überhaupt bei so einer Physis jemals zu seinem Wissen hat gelangen können. Meine einzige These war, er müsste eigentlich, er hat wahrscheinlich so das Trainingsgerät direkt am Rechner. Also während er darüber nachdenkt, was er als nächstes eingibt in sein System und während er so seine Feats liest, pumpt er einfach die ganze Zeit Gewichte.
Also der Einstein ist ja mal hin und her gelaufen beim Nachdenken und der stemmt wahrscheinlich Gewichte beim Nachdenken.
Ich will mich jetzt überhaupt nicht lächerlich machen. Das ist einfach so der Eindruck, den man hat. Auf der anderen Seite war er aber auch total der Denker-Typ. Also ein total ruhiger, voll durchtrainierter Kerl, aber halt so ein ganz ruhiger. Der sprach halt auch sehr ruhig.
Der war mit einem falschen Körper geboren.
Und er ist halt auch so die Hardcore-Fraktion, die sich eben um diese eigentliche Baseband-Geschichte kümmert. Also der Vortrag war sehr knapp. Es war halt der normale Stundenslot. Man hätte dem Team durchaus einen Doppelslot geben können eigentlich beim Kongress. Das hätte dem Vortrag sehr gut getan. Sie sind mit einer Höllengeschwindigkeit durch die Features durchgelatscht. Das war sehr schwierig zu folgen. Es war natürlich wie alle anderen Veranstaltungen auf dem Kongress rassig voll, sodass natürlich auch immer diese latente Unruhe und Leute, die dich irgendwie ablenken. Sie haben die gesamte Architektur des iPhones quasi dargelegt, wie alles miteinander geschützt ist und was bootet und wie kryptographisch gesichert ist. Ich wollte mir eigentlich den Vortrag noch mal in Ruhe anschauen, aber du sagtest, es gibt gar keine Aufzeichnung. Ich bin gar nicht dazu gekommen, eine zu suchen.
Doch, aber die war halt beschissen.
Okay, alles klar. Aber ich hatte jetzt auch leider die Zeit nicht mehr gefunden, mir es noch mal in Ruhe anzuschauen. Was ich so mitgenommen habe, war, erstens, das iPhone ist eine Burg, eine Festung. Sie haben da so viele Sachen offensichtlich ganz richtig gemacht. Also eine Kaskade von gesignetem Code.
Also vielleicht mal vorne weg, also ich weiß nicht, wie es dir ging. Mir ging es so, bei dem ersten Prozess, beim offiziellen Betriebssystem teil, hatte ich noch so einen groben Durchblick, wovon die reden. Und im Baseband war es dann wirklich okay.
Im Baseband wurde es wirklich, wirklich, wirklich schwierig.
Ich höre die Begriffe und ich habe so eine grobe Ahnung, was jetzt hier ungefähr ablaufen könnte.
Aber es waren nur noch so Farben eigentlich.
Es war so Nucleus. Das hatte ich schon mal gehört, aber das war es exakt. Also ich wusste nicht, was das Nucleus jetzt wirklich genau ist. Also das ist das Betriebssystem des Basebands, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ja, also der Baseband-Chip ist ja ein eigener armbasierter Chip. Das heißt ein eigener Prozessor, der seinen eigenen Code läuft, seine eigene Firmware sozusagen auf dem Chip läuft. Nucleus ist eine dieser Mikrocontroller-Betriebssysteme. Nucleus OS kannst du in deinem Wikipedia nachschlagen. Das ist durchaus verbreitet, das läuft da drauf. Und auch der Code, der da drauf läuft, ist halt durch verschiedene Kaskaden von Signierungen usw. geschützt. Ich kriege das jetzt alles nicht mehr so gut zusammen, wie das jetzt wirklich läuft. Also ich hoffe, dass wir vielleicht zur nächsten Sendung dann alle nochmal die Ruhe gefunden haben, uns den Vortrag anzuschauen und das nochmal genau aufzunehmen. Erstaunlich ist, wie dieses iPhone-Dev-Team, die sich halt auch alle nicht kannten, welche Energie die an den Tag legen, um das irgendwie alles zu hacken. Und allerdings hatte ich auch so den Eindruck, nur noch mit Glück haben sie überhaupt Lücken gefunden. Also Apple hat schon ein paar Fehler gemacht, aber es ist nicht grundsätzlich, sondern es sind immer so Fehler, die sie gemacht haben, die dann eben ausgenutzt wurden. Aber es ist nicht so, dass sie da grundsätzlich etwas total vergeigt hätten.
Also auf dem ersten iPhone, das ja mittlerweile ziemlich durchge-unlockt ist, da haben sie einen prinzipiellen Fehler gemacht. Und zwar die allererste ladende Instanz, die dieses Baseband-Betriebssystem lädt, lädt das Ganze unverschüsselt. Und wenn die, wenn man da einmal drin ist, ist man drin im Gerät und da sind sie drin. Das ist also die erste iPhone-Generation, und da hat Apple keine Chance mehr, jemals wieder was gegen zu machen. Und bei der zweiten Generation ist aber dieser Teil mitverschlüsselt.
Ich bin voll froh, dass es beim ersten so easy ist, dass man da eigentlich nichts mehr machen muss. Ich kann einfach updaten und mein Unlock bleibt weiterhin drin, das ist voll toll.
Und beim zweiten ist das jetzt auch so, da sind sie nach wie vor nicht reingekommen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, in dieses, in das Baseband. Sie haben es nicht entschlüsselt.
Und auch nicht in den Bootloader halt. Also sie können auch kein anderes Baseband reinschieben bisher.
Genau. Was sie aber geschafft haben, ist, sie haben eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden. Also sie schaffen es, einen Buffer-Overflow, vermute ich mal, zu provozieren im Baseband, schaffen es dadurch, eigenen Code reinzuschieben. Und dadurch wird zur Laufzeit das Baseband geanlockt. Also es ist nicht wie beim alten, es wurde eine eigene Software draufgeschrieben, auf das Ding und damit hat sich der Salat. Und ab sofort ist das, wie Denis jetzt gerade richtig sagte, auch nach einem Update ist das da noch drin. Sondern es findet eigentlich gar keine Veränderung auf dem Gerät selber statt, was natürlich auch mal relativ elegant ist sogar. Es ist eine reine Software zur Laufzeit-Modifikation. Wenn ich den Anlock nicht mehr haben will, dann deinstalliere ich ihn wieder und dann ist er weg. Aber es wird, woran man sich bei der ersten Generation gewöhnt hatte, 2-3 Tage nachdem das Software-Update von Apple rauskam, ist auch der neue Anlock da, weil die müssen ja bloß nochmal kurz durchtesten und gucken, dass auch weiterhin alles funktioniert und schon ist alles super. Das wird in Zukunft nicht mehr so sein, sondern Apple wird natürlich schön hinterher sein, genau diese Lücken immer zu schließen, die sie ausgenutzt haben. Und dann kann man nur hoffen, dass sie zu dem Zeitpunkt, wenn jetzt der nächste Betriebssystem-Update rauskommt, schon eine neue Lücke gefunden ist, die noch nicht bis Apple durchgedrungen ist. Und irgendwann könnte das mal wirklich heißen, Scheunenlicht, wenn ich das so richtig gesehen habe.
Da kommt endlich unendlich, ewig immer wieder neue Bassband-Versionen raus, weil für das alte Telefon gibt es ja auch schon seit ewig kein neues Bassband-Update mehr.
Aber für das 3G machen sie relativ regelmäßig mal Bassband-Updates.
Na ja klar, aber auch nicht mehr ewig, so bis Ende des Jahres vielleicht, sondern hört das langsam auf.
Wieso? Jetzt haben sie eine Motivation, weiter neu zu machen, das Unlock-Team auszusperren.
Na, glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, die bringen keine Software-Updates raus, nur damit sie das Unlock-Team aussperren können.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, weil ich meine gerade solange es sich auch um Sicherheitslücken handelt. Also ich meine, so ist es.
Es ist ja nochmal was anderes. Obwohl, okay, sind auch immer in Sicherheit.
Andere Leute könnten solche Exports auch für andere Sachen nutzen, und dann fahren die Leute halt ein. Das Problem ist auch, wenn Apple, wenn iPhones in the wild mit einer Baseband-Version fahren, die einfach Scheiße baut, wenn Netze damit sozusagen in Unsicherheit gebracht werden und GSM-Netze sind bedroht durch Rogue Phones. Weil das bringt sozusagen das Gleichgewicht dieser Netze durcheinander. Man guckt ja an, was in IP-Netzwerken abgeht, wie da Attacken gefahren werden, DOS und so weiter. Das findet in GSM nur deshalb nicht statt, weil eigentlich alle im Einsatz befindlichen Telefone lizenziert sind und diese Baseband ist hoch- und heilig abgesichert, und in the air und schnickes. Du kannst einfach kein Telefon rausbringen.
GSM scheint exorbitant unsicher zu sein.
Und natürlich ist es das, weil es einfach ein System ist, das auf Vertrauen basiert. Das Vertrauen, dass es überhaupt keine Telefone gibt, die sich nicht nach der Norm verhalten.
Da gab es ja diesen ziemlich beeindruckenden Vortrag über SS7 jetzt auf Kongress, dass man darüber jede Person lokalisieren kann.
Genau, wenn wir das iPhone-Thema damit jetzt abgeschlossen haben, kann man ja nochmal nachlegen. Ich habe schon lange keine Veranstaltung mehr gesehen, auf der so viele populäre Technologien Lebewohl gesagt wurde. Das war ja wirklich eine einzige Verabschiedung von bestehender Infrastruktur. Hattest du auch den Eindruck, Denis?
Hier mit dem ganzen Zeug, was sie gehackt haben, mit Deckt und so?
Ja. Deshalb ist keiner mehr davon gekommen. Also Deckt ist komplett gebrochen. Deckt ist einfach durch.
Das ist schon ein bisschen länger her?
Was gab es denn bei DNS neu?
Nix Neues, das ist schon länger her. Das war einfach nochmal erzählt.
Der hat nochmal erklärt, wie es läuft. Auch ein schöner Fortschritt. Zisco-Exploit, den irgendwie FX gefunden hat, wo er irgendwie alle Geräte mit aufmachen kann.
Zisco ist durch ein einfaches Ping, und Zisco ist jeder, das kann man immer pauschal sagen, durch einen einfachen Ping in ausnutzbaren, beliebigen Zustand zu bringen.
Dann den SS7-Talk habe ich nicht gesehen, aber auch da gab es Bedrohliches. Dann wurde das, also SS7 ist das Singling von digitalen Telefonennetzwerkvermittlungsstellen untereinander.
Hier das Telefonennetzwerk dieser Welt funktioniert im Augenblick noch, unter anderem GSM und ISDN und Analog.
Dann sind alle Nokia-Telefone geschrottet durch diese böse SMS, die man verschickt, die irgendwie einen E-Mail-Modus hat. Dann kommen die Telefone nicht damit klar, weil sowas eben normalerweise keiner verschickt. Wenn das wirklich mal kommt, hängen die sich auf und zwar auf eine Art und Weise, dass sie eben zwar noch als Telefon funktionieren, aber keine SMS mehr empfangen.
Sag mal Timme, da fällt mir gerade ein, hast du eigentlich irgendwann mal so einen Teilroman auf deinem iPhone-Screen bekommen? So eine Art Special Service SMS, die so direkt angezeigt wird und so den komplettes iPhone, also so ganz vorne angezeigt wird und alles andere überblendet? Hat man ja im Club irgendwie rumgespielt mit so Special Service SMS und so und auf meinem Telefon wurden richtig über die gesamte Seite wurden die angezeigt.
Kann ich mir das grob so vorstellen, dass sozusagen der Dialog ragte bis über den entriegelten Bildschirm unten drunter rüber?
Ja, das wurde direkt oben drüber gemacht, mit Scrollen glaube ich sogar.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, aber das war mit Firmware 1.1.2 oder irgendwie sowas, mit einer ganz, ganz langen Herfirmware, ist das iPhone nicht mit alphanumerischen Absendern klar gekommen. Und dann hat es die SMS komplett verhauen.
Also jetzt wo du gerade sagst, iPhone, stelle ich gerade fest, dass mein iPhone vor einer anderthalb Stunde komplett abgestürzt ist, während jemand angerufen hat.
War toll, aber der Akku ist noch nicht leer.
Ich habe einfach nur leise gestellt und es nicht klingeln lassen und jetzt stelle ich gerade fest, dass er eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit in diesem Modus hängt. Hast du mir jetzt gerade so eine SMS geschickt, Denis?
Nee, nicht, wir hätten keine Sitz- über Neujahr machen sollen.
Oh, jetzt kommen sie uns zu holen. Naja, wie auch immer. Also auf jeden Fall, die Kongress-Videos sind auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
Ach so, und SSL ist natürlich noch flöten.
Nee, Md5 meint er. Md5 ist heftig.
Ja, aber damit auch?
Ja, das sind die Zertifikate, die kann man eben auch mit was anderem als Md5 machen.
Klar, aber es gäbe theoretisch da draußen die Möglichkeit, Zertifikate, die jetzt schon existieren, könnten durchaus gesetzter.
Kann man auf jeden Fall faken, ja. Also der Kongress hat einiges zu bieten. Ich hoffe, dass auf chaosradio.ch, CDE auch bald alle Videos als Podcast angeboten werden können, bzw. überhaupt erstmal der Podcast angeboten werden kann und dann schrittweise alle Videos, die es so gibt und veröffentlicht werden, dort kommen. Das ist allerdings eine Zeitfrage. Und die Antwort auf diese Frage ist gerade nein. Haben wir noch was, Denis?
Weiß nicht. Was ist denn mit Apple? Die haben doch so wieder ein Teil von einer Firma investiert, oder? Imagine oder sowas?
Ja, das ist die Bude, die diese PowerVR-Chip-Technologie baut. Also die 3D-Technologie, die im iPhone zum Einsatz kommt, bzw. eigentlich in allen Telefonen. PowerVR ist der definitive Industriestandard für 3D-Grafik und beschleunigte Grafik in mobilen Devices und Apple, meines Wissens auch, haben da Anteile gekauft. Und das geht ja eigentlich alles wunderbar zusammen. Da haben wir schon mal drüber geredet. Sie haben ja auch diese andere Bude, wie hieß die noch gleich, die diese PowerPC-Prozessoren hergestellt hat. Die haben sie ja gekauft mit dem ehemaligen Entwickler von Star Strong Arm Architektur als Chef. Die sind ja mittlerweile eine eigene Abteilung bei Apple. Und mittlerweile ist ja auch klar, die arbeiten quasi an dem nächsten iPhone-Prozessor. Und meiner Meinung nach bestätigt auch jetzt dieses Investment bei PowerVR, bei der Bude, die PowerVR macht. Ja, das ist die Imaginative, Imaginetech, Imaginetech heißt das glaube ich, bestätigt im Prinzip, was sie vorhaben. Sie haben ein eigenes Team. Sie entwickeln ihren eigenen Prozessor auf ARM-Basis mit PowerVR drin und wahrscheinlich mit allem anderen, was sie gerne in so einem Telefon integriert haben möchten, auf einem Chip. Das heißt, sie werden die Integrationslichte erhöhen. Sie haben damit natürlich die Chance, auch sehr stromsparend zu arbeiten. Das ist jetzt sozusagen eine reine Vermutung. Warum sollten sie auf irgendwas anderes zielen? Wie erfolgreich sie jetzt damit sein werden, das wird man dann sehen. Auf jeden Fall haben sie total Experten am Start. Und ich vermute, dass das nächste iPhone, das 3.0-iPhone, mit einem Stein arbeiten wird, den die entwickelt haben.
Na, wenn es das bringt und schnell und flott und batterischohnt und klar.
Ja, und da werden sie alles irgendwie reinbauen, was sie irgendwie reinbauen können, was ihnen weiterhilft. Und damit sind sie eben auch weniger kopierbar. Weil derzeit verwenden sie technische Komponenten, die eben auch andere kaufen können. Damit können die sich eben so ein Ding zusammenbauen, so wie Microsoft ja mit dem Xeon eigentlich auch nur den iPod nachgebaut hat. Also das ist das, was hinter diesem Investment steckt. Und ich denke, das macht Sinn. Der Wert des Ladens wird auch steigen. Ja, mit dem Xeon können wir ja vielleicht aufhören. Weil das war ja noch wirklich...
Da hat der Xeon ja auch aufgehört.
Ja, ich überlege jetzt gerade. Also was passiert, alle First-Generation 30 GB Xeons sind am 31.12.2008 stehen geblieben. Weil...
Dass der 366. Tag war. Und es gibt ja im Jahr nur 365, oder?
Nee, es gibt den... Man kann sich den bei Dick tauchte, der Coat tatsächlich dafür auf.
Ja, ich hab mir den nicht wirklich angeschaut, dass du reingeguckt hast, was da läuft.
Das sind nur 5 Zeilen oder sowas. Der ist halt gelobt, weil er halt mit dem 366.
Tag nicht klarkam.
Genau, also er kommt mit mehr als 365 Tagen klar. Er kommt mit mehr als 366 Tagen klar. Aber er kommt nicht mit exakt 366. Also er kommt nicht mit dem 366.
Und dann ist da eine Endlosschleife.
Und dann hängt da eine Endlosschleife. Und das ist eine Weisschleife.
Microsoft hat gesagt, der Fix ist ganz easy, ihr müsst die Kisten einfach nur laufen lassen bis morgen oder bis sie leer sind und dann morgen wieder einschalten. Und einen Fix machen wir, bis das Problem wieder kommen sollte, weil jetzt haben wir vier Jahre Zeit. Genau, weil es wieder vier Jahre passieren wird.
Und sie waren überrascht, dass noch so viele 30 GB Zions im Einsatz sind.
Aber es war nicht Microsofts Fehler, sondern es war irgendwie Set-Party-Code.
Das ist ja auch bei diesem Samsung-Gerät, glaube ich, war das. Also bei dem Schwestergerät von Zions ist genau das gleiche Problem aufgetreten. Alles für die User. Dieses Gerät haben sie ja geweint.
Nun ja, ich würde sagen, haben wir jetzt noch irgendwelche Fragen, Antworten. Wir sind jetzt schon wieder ganz schön lange, oh, wir sind schon wieder zweieinhalb Stunden dabei. Oder? Ja. Und ich würde sagen, so reicht es erstmal. Gucken wir mal, dass wir vielleicht zu der iPhone-Thematik noch mal ein bisschen besseren Überblick nächstes Mal bieten können, wenn wir die Zeit dafür haben.
Welche Thematik mit dem Anloggen?
Es ist sehr viel darüber gesagt worden, wie diese iPhone wirklich intern aufgebaut ist. Aber das muss man sich hier wirklich noch mal in Ruhe geben von der Auszeichnung.
Also das, was ich gesehen habe, war übersaturiert. Ich hoffe, es gibt irgendwie noch ein besseres Video, weil das war auch ein Video, wo man nur die Slides gesehen hat, nicht die Leute selbst leider, weil ich habe den Muscle Nerd nicht gesehen. Und vielleicht gibt es ja, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kameras, die da so hatten, aber wenn das das Einzige ist, dann ist das unbrauchbar.
Also ich habe gerade eben eins runtergeladen, das sieht nicht, das sieht erstmal so, ich habe es noch nicht hier, ich habe es erst mal nur zu Hause auf dem Rechner. Das sieht erstmal nicht so übersaturiert aus, aber es ist tatsächlich auch nur die Slides. Genau wie bei dir. Und Ton habe ich jetzt noch nicht.
Wobei die Slides sind eigentlich das Wichtigste. Also das ist nur schwierig, weil sie zwischendurch, wie sie auch selbst zugegeben haben, dass es nicht so klug war. Die hat es halt immer so vor zurück, vor zurück, durch so bestimmte Slides. Das ist ein bisschen anstrengend.
Wir waren wahrscheinlich richtige Hardcore-Nerds, sind halt nicht so die Vorträger.
Jaja, teilweise konnten wir das ganz gut, aber das war okay.
Den Vortragstier fand ich irgendwie super.
Und ich hab auch so... Irgendwie hab ich mir mit Skriptkiddies gerechnet. Das waren schon durchaus Leute, bei denen ist mein iPhone in sicheren Händen.
Tja, auf jeden Fall haben die Plan. So, haben wir's?
Haben wir's, oder?
Meine Damen und Herren, ja. Max, Denis, vielen Dank. Denis, wärt gesund, dass wir das nächste Mal uns wieder live anhauchen können.
Ich hör grade, dass die iPhone-Nerds nicht gefilmt werden wollten.
Ah, alles klar. Verstehe.
Hab hier Special Contacts hier im Chat.
Ah ja, okay, verstehe. Das heißt, es wird nur ein Video mit Slides geben, aber das reicht auch. Also man muss die nicht sehen. Die saßen da halt alle steif und das war's. Dann war das sozusagen der Vorteil, den man hatte, wenn man im Saal war.
Ja, ich müsste sogar noch irgendwo ein Foto, ich hab von denen ein Foto gemacht, aber nun sehr schlecht, das mit dem iPhone.
Nächstes Mal bei Mobile Max, hoffentlich dann schon mit neuen Mac-Minis, neuen iMacs.
Über die wir berichten können, ohne sie damals gesetzt werden.
Und noch eine kurze Future-Frage meint er, dass die neuen, coolen Batterien, die nicht zylindrisch sind und deswegen mehr Power haben und so auch für die aktuellen MacBook Pros rauskommen?
Nein.
Ich denke, sie werden alles darauf umstellen. Sie werden gar keinen Austausch machen.
Ja, umstellen schon, aber nicht zum Nachkaufen.
Also nicht, dass man, wenn man jetzt schon MacBook Pros gekauft hat, dass es dann die neuen Akkotypen gibt.
Genau, das Apple sagt hier, wir haben jetzt die neuen Akkotypen verkauft und hat jetzt irgendwie 30 Prozent mehr als der alte und so, glaube ich nicht. Haben die nämlich noch nie so wirklich gemacht für ältere Geräte neuere, coolere Sachen rausgebracht.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das so einfach ist, weil sie haben irgendwas erzählt von wegen, dass sie ein neues Lade-Management hätten.
Na ja, Apple übertreibt auch gerne beim Markt.
Ja klar, ich meine, die haben an vielen Punkten dabei übertrieben, aber auf jeden Fall, dass da wohl, also ich meine, ganz so dumm, wie sie da getan haben, wird ein Akku schon seit, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr geladen oder sowas. Einfach Strom ran und warten, was passiert.
Alle Akkus zwischen ihren eigenen Ladechip irgendwie mit drin schon, also es ist ja gar nicht geben.
Genau, aber insofern kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass es gar nicht dann so unglaublich einfach auch ist, dass man dann eine höhere Ladungsspannung bräuchte oder irgendwie sowas, aber das ist jetzt wirklich reines Rum.
Ich rechne mit einem neuen Update von Macbook und Macbook Pro irgendwann immer halben Jahr und dann stellen die das auch auf feste Akkus um.
Das denke ich auch eher, so um April oder so.
Und dann sollte irgendwie auch alles, ja, dann vielleicht auch länger laufen, wenn es überhaupt so viel bringt, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Hauptsache, man kann die Festplatte danach noch so leicht wechseln, wie das jetzt der Fall ist. Ah ja, und USB 3.0 können sie ja gleich noch einbauen und überhaupt.
E-Sata.
Ja, und so eine ausziehbare Kaffeetassenwärmer wäre auch ganz gut.
Überziehbares Zweit-Display, was man dann die doppelte Bildschirmgröße haben kann.
Ja, oder gleich so sechsfach, also einmal hochklappen und dann nach links und nach rechts ausklappen.
Oder gleich holographisch in den Raum rein.
Ja.
Ja, so Proector-Style, geil.
Aber das muss dann auch wieder von Steve kommen, also wenn Phil das machen würde, würde ich sagen so, hoh, Holodisplay, was für ne Scheiße.
Du meinst, es ist einfach nicht so toll, wenn es nicht von Olle Steve kommt.
Ja, das kann es nicht sein.
So ist es. In diesem Sinne, sagen wir mal schön Tschüss, oder? Und bis bald bei MobileMax. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und in zwei Wochen hoffentlich gibt's uns dann wieder. Tschüss. Tschüss.